i'm going to be honest the suck is
hitting and i don't know
why let's turn it from a discussion to a
[ __ ] bar conversation if i wasn't
just [ __ ] shouting at each other it's
the shittiest episode
oh he's actually downing it okay should
definitely watch this with a drink of
wine or sake or
i'm the host for one time with a guest
chris broad again
hello oh that was like the weakest intro
i have ever heard honestly i'm a little
this i'm a little disappointed
hello and welcome to this episode of
trash taste i was talking gone
unfortunately as you know corona is
still going on so we weren't actually
able to get any
significant guests so we asked chris to
come
heartbreaking please
back here he says he's our most viewed
episode yeah exactly
thank you so much for coming back chris
good to be back in the church the anime
bill yeah
it's nice
it's also nice getting to talk to you
after we've you know become a bit more
familiar because it actually was the
first time we'd ever met when you came
on the podcast yeah it was really
nerve-wracking last time was it scary
why really no no now we're friends
yeah reluctantly of course
now you've helped us film like our
drifting special we're shifting yeah
yeah
we unfortunately like didn't get a
proper chance to introduce you in that
episode
and you you were just kind of just kind
of just showed up
very scuffed very slip shot i i don't
know what i was expecting some sort of
grand entrance
we talked about me like rocking up in a
car and be like hey everyone in the end
all abroad no it's nothing just like me
in the back of the
opening shot was just dying in the back
of the car while joey was in the front
really glad i got involved with that
project
it's like a really quick pandas but it
was a lot of fun it was honestly
nice to be behind the camera yeah um
watching joey be sick and it's great it
is nice shooting someone else's video
because you're like if this [ __ ] up
not my problem
yeah if it all goes wrong i'm good it's
fun just like flying the drone i was
trying to crash it into the car
like yeah i wanted you to yes yeah when
you were like like
charging towards yeah yeah do you like
do you like being behind the camera like
more than in front of the camera or vice
versa i do i like being behind the
camera
i do prefer being behind the camera
really i'm way more conscious of how i'm
presenting and
you know just fun filming but presenting
is tough like i get the impression you
prefer presenting more than filming
right oh no i i mean
i prefer being the in like the producer
director role
where i can just tell people what to do
and i have like a vision of my project
rather than
being on the project itself um i am
awful representing i think and that's
why these two are on camera more than me
i don't i just don't think i have enough
experience behind the camera
right to really know if i like being
behind the camera more than in front of
it
i do like presenting but it really
stresses me out when you're also
presenting the director the producer and
like everything is like everyone's like
looking at you for direction it's like
well i can't do everything come on like
you can give me a hand yeah because you
know some shoes obviously rock up to and
like
they're like so what have your planned
car i'm like i don't know what do you
mean we were just going to start
filming stuff like i have no idea and
then it's a bit hard to present because
it's like this is
a coffee in this cafe
and it's just kind of awkward it's like
how your videos go it's like yeah we'll
fix it in post
we'll fix it in post
i just like to imagine like that's how
you are on the actual filming day and
then somehow in post it just turns into
hey guys welcome back
there are lots of moments where i'm like
i'll just say something and then
obviously
it just cuts into a smooth transition
voiceover what actually happens is i
just say something and i'm like
why is that good real good everyone's
just like looking at me i'm confused i'm
like
all right we'll just do the next thing
we'll go to the next thing yeah yeah
that's that's what that's what i learned
from the acaba episode that we did where
it was my first time actually filming
out in the open and
i because i i didn't know when to stop
talking
like that because when a sentence is
fine when no one's directing you i
wasn't used to just being like
okay silence is that good did we cut
there uh do i keep talking i don't know
did i
present enough information i guess yeah
because all of the all of geeks videos
are scripted right yeah yeah so it's
like a completely different experience
being like well i know if it's scripted
where to pause
i thought about this you you do get used
to though i think
eventually just being like all right the
camera's always on it's whatever
i'll just relax when i'm done saying
what i need to say yeah but i think when
you initially have it you're like [ __ ]
[ __ ] being recorded
fbi is going to get this footage i'm
still not used to filming in public
i feel like i i don't i i can do videos
like off script because i've done yeah
stuff i've done on-script stuff but when
it's outside with just
random people watching me i feel there's
like a weird pressure of like oh people
are
probably watching me judging me yeah and
i can't
because so like that's why i could never
understand people who have the balls to
like
walk out you know in the middle of
shinjuku or whatever and just start
vlogging by themselves i don't know how
people do that i i think that's why i
like i like getting permission because
when i found permission i feel like it's
the green light oh yeah
yeah exactly when there's no permission
though i kind of have to you just be
like
they don't find it i hate secretly
when you did your recent amazing video
series chris
really great stuff uh your journey to
mount fuji right
journey to mount fuji what is it called
i just watched
the world you're amazing serious i don't
remember the name what was that again
across japan escape to fiji [ __ ] hell
chris that's a mouthful
come
i was running because you filmed in
daiso did you have to ask them before or
did you just rock up with the cameras
so fun fact when the only places in
japan you can film without needing
permission
really
[Music]
as i've normalized now you can go in you
can film that tomorrow news
how did you find that just common
knowledge i know there's a silence like
pictures are okay
right but i don't know if that means
rock up with your film crew and go
inside and start
this is chris broad and here is a
plastic hand
for 300 years
because in my head chris sounds way more
british than he is
right so i i think like what do you mean
he's the most british man alive
no no no no he's not come on conor's
accent is more british than mine really
from like wales
there's people who watch me who say the
uh the opposite they say that i don't
sound british enough and that you sound
proper british
because yeah chris broad's voice and
abroad in japan's voice i feel like two
different voices
they definitely like your presenting
accent is a lot more british i feel than
your just regular talking accent i don't
know i don't know i don't know
i i i feel like i've i've known you long
enough now i just get
lost i know when you start talking i
know when you're in like
presenter mode i think yeah when i'm a
presenter i'm more cynical sarcastic and
unpleasant
not like that in real life [ __ ] off
you're like that normally yeah i was
thinking i'm supposed to say it
unbelievable it was fun because when we
filmed the the
drifting video and we were in the hotel
i was like oh my god chris is just like
exactly like me
just absolutely [ __ ] chris is just
[ __ ] miserable and
complains about everything oh my god
it's exactly the same i mean that's just
the most british trait yeah
that's just any brit who goes abroad
right
and that's why brits rarely go like
abroad to places that other brits
haven't already been to
yeah like hearing hearing about a brit
who goes to asia we're like the weird
ones
yeah you know what i mean to be fair
that's true that's true normally we just
stick in europe
or like [ __ ] zanti or one of the
[ __ ] islands right
i don't [ __ ] where the [ __ ] is zanzi
that's one of the [ __ ] islands it's a
bunch of party i love
ibiza
they just sound like game of thrones
locations to me like splendid
the island of santi what is this you've
given me it's
it's cheap it's game of thrones
our sponsor this is like my first time
to drink it yeah so i'm a bit nervous
the way it all looking at me
are you gamified now
like a trip it's delicious what is it
it's like fizzy
it's not fizzy but it's like really sour
and it's like an especially like an
energy drink
i don't know what flavor you have pink
lemon oh you have pink lemonade pink
lemonade does it
do something what like energizes you
chris
you went to an epic game again when i
saw maylene pouring it she was like
[Music]
you're going to enjoy this i mean that's
that's just that's just me
that's just me
probably what does that mean oh yeah
because it's supposed to be it's like
energy drink right
it's it's gamer fuel g-fuel how does the
first
drink of 2021 taste oh yes this is the
first episode
to all of our viewers we survived live
we survived well hopefully
because this is filmed before the new
year so who do you [ __ ] know
that's morbid isn't it it was the last
time that the trash days boys were seen
with chris broad but i mean yeah 20 20.
not a great year
it will be good hopefully fingers
crossed you guys have any hopes for the
new year
i think 2020 has taught me to know my
place with expectations i think
about it i thought maybe i could spend
more than two hours outside at a time
i don't know just go i went on the
psycho line today have you ever been on
the psychiatric
psycho center oh there's [ __ ] jr line
there is some sort of self-help line
honest honestly honestly i i need it
after going on it like
this morning because i go to class at
like 8 a.m so it's rush hour right yeah
and the
this it's [ __ ] insane so when you go
up to the platform there's so many
people waiting that like they go to the
next platform and start like curling
off the side yeah and then it's just a
it is literally like as you saw in the
videos and they squish people on i
thought that was just like a oh
you've never been in that position
before well i've been on that now i have
every week
but but i never used to see it as a
tourist because i never used to go at
like the 8 a.m trains
it's not as bad in the evenings but
definitely
in the morning it's horrible and right
now with kovacs
avoid trains between seven to eight
thirty it's one a.m
i mean i still think it's pretty bad in
the evenings as well but not as bad like
you you can
when there's a question of hmm how many
people do i have to push forward to get
on this train and then maybe just about
like [ __ ] myself
like that's that's a little bit too hard
yesterday when i finished at around
6 00 p.m i feel like i feel like 6 p.m
is probably like the worst time to go
home
because i i remember it was it was the
same point where you know
like if you think about how to get in
the train and i thought the best way to
get in this train is to do a [ __ ]
run-up
so we tackle them [ __ ] rugby tackle
my way through
to get space and they just close with my
backpack
like touching the door yeah i i love
all these like just really you know
skinny like train
attendants just [ __ ] doing a full-on
rummy slice yeah because they
they all grow up yeah they push they
push them in it's just like a rugby
match
right they treat it like a like you know
how someone like get their car stuck in
mud like
get out push it put give it a push get
out come on come on steve give it a give
it a good push
and like i'm there and i'm like is there
an etiquette when the train is that
packed like because i'm crushing this
like these old ladies in this corner
and i can't do anything because i'm like
[ __ ] the force of zeus against this
door trying to like
stop myself from but when it's like
eight people's just like
squishing i'm like [ __ ] god and you do
that like on a daily
oh at least once a week sometimes twice
a week i think that the reason why they
have to do that in the morning is
because they
don't want anyone to be late to work
yeah but all all those trains
always are delayed that that one well
yeah specifically exactly because
there's two
people so counterintuitive and then when
it gets delayed more people
are waiting for the train and it's just
it's an absolute mess it's a [ __ ] storm
i don't appreciate it sort that out
tokyo
and if i get if i if i got the rona you
know how the [ __ ] would you contact
trace
like oh no so who was the psychologist
so who was in the train which 10 000 of
you also had it you know what i mean
like what
it's scary it'd be easier to say who
wasn't on this yeah yeah
it's scary man yeah daunting i'm just
like what do i do if i get it
[ __ ] all right well [ __ ] have you ever
been on like uh
that kind of morning rush because you
know when you're yeah
quite a bit and i yeah i've done it and
i learned my lesson never to do it again
because it's not that bad up in the
north right over the north lane
yeah yeah i'm sure if i started coughing
they'd all run away
they'd make room have you done that no
no dude
when i get a sneeze now i have like this
zen moment of
hold hold up any form of coughing or
anything any noise
noise like coughing is okay but sneeze
is like
it's [ __ ] scary because you people
always look and
like even when i'm wearing a mask i'm
just like do i just sneeze or do i
sneeze into my hand or like
elbow what is the right hand he's way
too loud to sneeze into my elbow
you know what's the best way actually to
stop a sneeze there's a there's
a pressure point there's a pressure
point right here on your top lip and if
you push that hard enough it actually
doesn't
do that in public all right like
how does that work honestly it works
like i've had so many times where i've
wanted to sneeze and publicly there's a
better technique rub here
right like that yeah and that's better
than going like that in it i just
screamed
just go like that it looks like you know
you're just you're just massaging your
nose like well yeah no i'm not saying to
do
this
but like it does work you can kind of
just like do like i usually i usually do
with my face
just imagine chris is on the train
[Music]
like that but i usually do it kind of
like with my thumb just very subtly like
that and it stops it every time i
thought it was [ __ ] too
because it was it's the one piece of
information that i saw in japanese tv
and i was like oh wow oh come on that's
no they they
say stuff like yeah [ __ ] your pants to
get rid of and you would start [ __ ]
doing it
they're an absolute bunch of numbers i
thought that's why i thought oh it's
probably [ __ ] but you know what i'll
give it a go and i tried it out once and
i was like
okay maybe that was a coincidence i did
it twice i was like then
you know what i i need some actual like
i want a subreddit
for things of it's probably [ __ ] but
i'll give it a go it's like
you know what i'm pretty sure there is
something i hope so like
your [ __ ] grandma's like grandma's
tails japanese tv
facts i'm i'm curious about 2020 because
obviously you've been making content in
japan
how much has it changed making content
traveling around japan and
what kind of like big differences have
you seen has there been any like major
differences
apart from the like people having well
you've got to wear a mask yeah
like it's kind of hard it's a bit hard
to present in the match they're
presenting with the mask outdoors
i gotta say one of the one of the one of
the highlights of 2020 was watching
chris with a beer go through his spam
comments
just
i'm yeah on the hunt for like ridiculous
comments um
and we certainly had a few like uh on
the second day of the road trip we did
somebody told me i was disrespectful for
not enjoying the taste of the bee lol
yeah yeah we didn't like it yeah he was
sick
and someone's like you're disrespectful
to the japanese for not liking hornet
larvae
but the woman who sold it
to us was like i don't like this this is
[ __ ] it's not like you said to her oh
this looks [ __ ] disgusting
it was it was really weird that sort of
comment triggered me that triggered me
right yeah it was it was a trigger wow
as if as if that person commenting was
like well i personally love bee larvae
how dare you
the hornet love my family's been
producing bee lava for generations i'll
have you know
i'm a third generation harvester oh it's
like like
foreign folks who feel they need to
defend japan often come up a lot in my
comments and
yeah yeah but people like that i find
usually haven't they never actually
traveled to japan right here
have never traveled outside of their
country actually yeah
like it's got nothing to do with their
like i would understand a little more if
it was a japanese person
who was getting offended for japanese
culture right that makes sense
but usually it's like it's not it's just
people being like woke
you know yeah like i remember um back
when i was living in thailand like my
mom
tried to get sydney to wear like this
very traditional thai dress
and sydney was like um yeah i don't know
about that because like a lot of people
can get offended because of like
cultural appropriation and stuff like
that
and my mom was like what's cultural
appropriation
and like having to explain the concept
of cultural appropriation
was just completely [ __ ] impossible
to like
it's like a you know like a asian mum
right right
it just it just like did not compute
that why would anyone
get offended on behalf of mike yeah of
me
oh it's because before the word cultural
appropriation came about it was called
cultural appreciation
you know and now there's such a thin
line between what is appreciation and
what is appropriate
right yeah it's if you take too much you
know right it's like
is a white person wearing a kimono is
that appreciation or is that appropriate
if someone started shagging sheep i
would be like hold on that's my thing
i think a lot of the time like you said
it's the the people themselves are like
yeah
dude we want you to experience our
culture we want you to share it
right like it's like a [ __ ] all these
like people who are
you know when ghost of tsushima came out
there's so many people like oh this game
is
it's such cultural appropriation to you
know the whole like samurai culture
thing
people said that yeah yeah yeah when the
game first came out i saw there was this
huge thing about it and
it was really funny because there was a
guy who gathered a bunch of uh
uh reviews or like i guess like you know
uh customer reviews of japanese people
who play the game and they were like
nah dude it's cool yeah yeah white
people please go ahead make a game about
samurais
yeah be cool if it's like if they're
obviously respectful towards it who
doesn't want a [ __ ] video game about
where they like that they're just
badass but there was this whole thing of
like oh it's a western company making a
game about japanese culture
it's like so if they can do it correctly
then what's the problem
how dare japanese people make bread
that's that's we made we
started there how dare they make our
bread
it's just dumb i've seen like especially
recently just with the whole pc culture
thing it's just
there's no one can be culturally
appreciative of things anymore without
at least one person saying how dare you
that's offensive
right yeah i mean i think because it's
like it's like people want brownie
points on twitter right
right because there are legitimate cases
of people just being disrespectful
yeah yeah i think some people see that
and they're like oh
if i do that next time i'll get twitter
clout i'll get followers right so the
next opportunity that comes up they're
like
immediately like on it and then
everyone's like well i mean
not really and that's the thing right
it's like i you know you know bad intent
when you see it oh yeah yeah right and
just some people are just so
clouded by that i mean you'd think you'd
know bad intent when you see it but some
people
it feels like some people are good at
bullshitting intent is just lost
in a lot of like in a lot of cases and
it's sometimes it's just
hard especially on twitter and like you
said some people are like chasing for
this oh yeah because some people are
like
actively looking for any example that
they can they can see
and it's it's created a culture where
you know sometimes you want to do
something where you want to post
something on twitter but you don't know
who's going to offend sometimes right
right um
yeah it's in a chris right yeah yeah
it's a tightrope in it
scared of saying anything so
i like things and everyone absolutely
happy in
let's be happy yeah let's just like stop
it and what better way to be happy
than having some success in japan you
drink a lot of suck at the start the new
year
i think i might have just made that up
you do now is this commonly
commonly known knowledge is the other
side of a dice so chris here's the thing
we have uh
right great break in the mirror start
the new year when you work in a japanese
office or a school like i used to like
you had to break a barrel of sake
with a principal and it's really awkward
because you got the principal
100 teachers watching in a barrel you're
probably seeing footage of like in front
of like shrines and stuff where they're
yeah
there's like three or four priests who
like get like a wooden mallet and then
just
crack oh i have seen that that's really
[ __ ] awkward because you smash it
and it just goes away and you just feel
like a dick oh sorry
oh can't drink it either right it's got
on the floor
[ __ ] chaos connor but we're not gonna
do that but hopefully at some point we
can drink that today
fantastic with your cool aid i don't
think we're
it but uh yeah this looks good i did i
did some socket tasting uh last week i
tried 14 different types of stuff
because i thought it was the best
oh yeah it wasn't for a video are you a
fan of that it wasn't fun
but i can't tell you the first thing
about it it's got floral undertones
i mean like the only thing i know is
like yeah this is the unfiltered stuff
which is
angel i it tends to give awful hangovers
though yeah i i haven't
gotten used to sake because it's like a
terrifying
every drink i'm terrified of getting
sake hangovers
like every time like i remember when i
came to japan as a tourist
and i would be like i would drink all
you can see or you can drink sake all
day long
and then i realized holy [ __ ] i just
want to die the day after oh dude like i
usually get pretty bad hangovers if i
drink a lot but when it's like a sake
exclusive
for some reason it gives me the worst
headaches it's like i usually get i
usually get like the stomach hangover
where my stomach gets really queasy but
with sake it all goes to the head right
yeah and i wake up with a
i don't know why i think it's because
you drink more of it because it tastes
it doesn't have a strong flavor
yeah it looks like water you think oh
it's pure and then you have like three
and then four and then you're [ __ ]
because it doesn't have it doesn't burn
nearly as much no no
especially the good ones as well yeah
yeah i enjoy the taste of sake i just
don't like the aftermath
it's like yeah you wake up in the
morning do you avoid it
it's one of those things where like
sometimes japanese people will invite
you to be like do you wanna
have sake with us and i'm like yeah of
course of course of course and then i'm
drinking
there are some pretty dicey ones but no
that's good stuff yeah we'll definitely
craft this
i've got something to share as well oh
new year's celebrations i'll i'll put it
over here stick it in the
side my crozowski can have it have a sit
it's not sake
it's more wine oh my gosh recently i
came back from koshu valley which is
basically it's it's not very well known
but it's kind of like the napa valley of
japan where it's this area
um and they make a [ __ ] ton of wine
and it's uh me and sydney go on it on a
yearly trip where we go to this the
wine tasting place where you pay like
it's now 15 bucks but you go down to
this cellar
and there's like hundreds of different
wines that you can try
unlimited unlimited amounts british
people
but this time we tried going to some of
the uh local
wine makers as well and there's like a
bunch like there's
there's a bunch just in walking distance
and uh these are this is one of the
wines that
i picked i love how this product has
slightly become an excuse for us
to keep buying each other alcohol and
being like oh isn't this nice
that's what i've noticed though recently
is that like the best
it gets to the age where i'm just like
man what what do people want christmas
or birthday
booze boosts because wine looks wine
looks pleasing as well like to give it
it's like you're classy i respect you
yeah your class take this
and i also have some uh wine grape
raisins
wine grape raisins and some wine grape
cakes
so wow great cake yes i love it i love
the english on this one
for adults a simple and homemade style
taste please enjoy the elegance
can't wait to destroy those with some
sake and wine yeah like i don't know
when i reached the age
that i started to appreciate wine
because i remember when i was a kid
these would give me the worst hangovers
it was it wasn't it wasn't like sake it
was wine boxed wine
yeah boxed wine right yeah of course
that's wine it's like drinking petrol
basically echo falls in the uk does that
was that the big old
like they're talking about the five
pound bomb you can get like yeah you can
get like three liters of wine for like
five
or four pound 20 or something why to get
smashed sure
it's horrible you're a student you got
to share i remember when i was a first
year student i used to drink like two
bottles of red wine every
like day um
[Music]
no i was in a bad place i think i think
i realized
like a relationship had ended uh just
before university i was like i'm just
going to ruin myself this year
and so i turned to wine and the results
were just dreadful
don't don't do that avoid wine you must
have like actually gained a lot of
weight from that because it's like
yeah i mean the hangovers and the things
i did so you know when you just want to
wipe
a whole year yeah from your mind
like this year basically yeah i guess
that's what all this is for
right jesus christ what are your hopes
for 2021 then after
i mean i think we all had hopes for 2020
that went down that yeah do you not feel
that like
surviving a year on youtube is a success
almost like every year you
you still no i i don't do it you're like
like i've i can't i come into every year
thinking this is my last year
and
i think if you get too comfortable this
platform has a way of sweeping it like
as a youtuber you just see people who
just fall off the
face of the planet in the span of like a
month yeah
right scary um like so many channels
disappear as quickly as they come and
they are quickly replaced with new and
upcoming challenges
what defines what leads to a channel
what leads to a channel to sort of
disappear do you think or
lose i think i i think as connor said
like most of the time it's
comfort i think it's yeah complications
over comfort just being like
you know i have all these subscribers i
you know a lot i don't of course i don't
want to say any names
but but you know there's a lot of
channels that are you know much more on
the higher subscriber range who
kind of are just like i can make
anything at this point and i'll probably
still get views
i think you're in a good spot where
you're you kind of have to keep going to
new things
with your content the way you've built
it has forced you to do that but
you know uh for a channel like my own i
could do i have reoccurring series and i
could just pump the same ones out
yeah but the videos that tend to do the
best on the war in japan i'm usually
just near my room
right the comments right yeah yeah i
feel maybe it's because you do that
now so like very often compared to what
but that like you have to on youtube
right because you can't constantly be
going and doing these like week long
but that's what i'm saying like if chris
did videos where you know you were just
in your room reading hate comments or
going through your spam or you're like
you know just
commentating verbally rather than
showing it then i feel people would
start to be like oh this is kind of
repetitive
yeah but i think it's the fact that you
just every so now and then throw it in
i think i just try and mix everything up
with the contour like one week i've got
like a bullet train next week
i've got hate mail the week after right
and that's and that's usually the best
that's usually the channels i feel that
survive is the ones that have variety
i feel like you've got to just keep them
surprising your audience nice
and original yeah but i hate the comment
that annoys me the most
uh i've all hate comments i'm excited
for this
i don't even know what to say because i
know everyone's going to start
commenting it right
it's like the comment which i get a few
times a year
this guy's run out of ideas
it's just like come on look at the stuff
i've tried to do this year like there's
so much weight
like i've always wanted i've always
wanted to ask people like what
constitutes us running out of ideas
i don't know like like what is it well
it's it's odd right because i feel like
a lot of youtube
comments are like do the same thing
again yeah like they're like yeah but
then on the other hand
he's running out of ideas
but what i don't understand is that
there are always people who every single
upload no matter what you do
they'll always be comments that say oh
it's run out of ideas i'm like you
wouldn't think that if i'd actually run
out of ideas
i wouldn't be uploading at all i've i've
had it every year for like eight years
now
after a year of doing it yeah i have
rubber
now
every year somebody like this channel's
picked so like 2014's what this
it's zenith it's not good it's going to
be [ __ ] now and then it went on to
get better like you know so that's the
comments i know more about your channel
than you do
everyone does think they're an expert
yeah because
they watch a lot and it's always you
know it always sucks as well because
whenever
i've had at least with me i've had a few
times where i have genuinely been like
oh [ __ ] i don't know what to do
with that guys he's actually ran out of
ideas you know like where i get like an
artist's block
and i don't know what to do right right
and i think
i'm gonna ask my audience right that's
that's always the worst item and
i and i go on twitter being like hey
guys what what what content would you
like to see
and there's always that really one
popular vote that's like
very vocally spoken about and you're
like well i guess people want to see it
99 of the time you make a video like
that it gets [ __ ] viewed obviously
yeah as well and i'm like oh it's the
[ __ ] vocal mind to be fair i do i do
ask sometimes because like
rhett there's sometimes there is like a
genius idea like one
i've never had more than one good idea
it's rarely the top voted one no it's
never
yeah yeah it's never the top voted one
and most of the ideas you get are just
kind of like just the recycled ideas
that anyone can all the top comments are
just like react to reddit memes please
it's like
no i'm good man i'm really good yeah
audience suggestions can be a slippery
slope yeah when is when when are the
audience going to get what they want
chris broad reacts to people reacting to
chris broads
people want us to do like a boat ride on
journey across japan
on a boat and do quite a fun day that's
that's a good idea i was like
what are you gonna do on the boat just
like complain about it
hey this episode is sponsored by mega
house have you ever wondered what would
happen
if an anime character and a rubik's cube
had a nice little baby
well you get a car action cube a what
a correction cube that's what it says
here her action cue
sorry i'm getting distracted by how fun
this cube is to play with
so did you know that it looks easy to
solve but isn't
there are correction cubes for every
fandom such as dragon ball
gundam naruto and more gudetama
collect all the correction cube figures
play with them
display them and enjoy a truly unique
collectible puzzle
look what i did oh wow you've killed
three i i destroyed for you i gave
naruto some fat
anime titties look at that i want to
give frieza some fat titties hold on the
figure size is 3.35 inches tall with
chibi details and seven connected parts
that can be twisted into various
arrangements
like this for instance
these are created by mega house and
distributed by bandar usa
did you also know that it's available
right now online on amazon target and
other retailers for only 14.99 14.99 i
know
that's one cent less than 15. damn what
a deal
did you also know that correction cube
is a 2021 finalist for toy of the year
in the collectible category no way
i can see look at this look at this
abomination that i created what did you
that's like nightmare for you like
freezer toilet so if you want to get
your own correction cube click that link
in the description down below to order
one today you can also vote for
correction cube for the 2021 toy of the
year competition by clicking the link
down in the description below voting
ends 5th of january and the winner will
be announced on the 12th of february
so thank you so much for sponsoring us
back to the video look like yeah
audience suggestions when we did journey
across the palm we have challenges every
day and one of the challenge
we got was cover yourselves in custard
and close your eyes while you're driving
it's like
there's funny and then there's like
crossing the line and crashing in a cut
like dying in a car crash with joey
covered in custody i don't know it's a
terrible way to go it's like i don't
know about your like personal finishes
dude but i don't think anyone wants to
watch two dudes covered in custard for
an entire video but then again
saying it out loud kind of on at night
yeah but
but even if you did that right there'd
be more comments to be like how dare
chris put other people's lives in danger
for his shitty years
or the fifth episode joey and i sat in
some plant pots
which were like these bathtubs
yeah hotel with some plant pots
identical matching uh plant pot
shaped bathtub yeah someone commented
saying that was disrespectful to the
plant
like to japanese okay
it's because it's because i think some
some viewers have this notion of japan
of
everything is very meticulous everything
is cultural and everything
bathtubs are not a part of japanese
culture if i go to a hotel and it's [ __ ]
i'm reviewing it and saying that it's
[ __ ] and if they give me a plant pot for
a bath i'm probably gonna be like well
that's a bit [ __ ] isn't it was it was
it was a porcelain bath exactly i mean
you know
we were like oh this is you know unique
weird thing that might spice up the
video a little bit but like
how i don't know how the [ __ ] would
disrespect i've been in another place
that had a bath like that and it was
just uncomfortable because it's like it
was very uncomfortable i got stuck
because
you're like a [ __ ] like gremlin in
this thing just like
oh very comfortable
a run for his money weird [ __ ] i can't
wait
i i really want to meet now you're going
to get such a [ __ ] character
that was like the first time i probably
got to speak and hang out with natsuki i
mean i've met nutsky once
at like an event that you did after the
first journey crosstalk does he still
call you jelly yeah he still calls me
jelly
yeah because i think he genuinely
thought my name was jelly at first well
he did yeah he was like where's jelly
i mean joey right really yeah i don't
mind it's a it's an endearing nickname
but i mean go back to the comments like
for all the
these silly comments for the vast
majority the comments are nice
somebody said to me uh like you know
when you reach a million
subscribers you're not you're not
supposed to read the comments but like i
do i do enjoy doing it because it feels
like when i produce a video it feels
like having a party
and when you release the video i agree
with the comments you kind of want to be
there and you want to talk to people and
see what they think and
yeah it's the only way you can have that
engagement with the audience
i think i think the i i read the
comments on the first two
first day or so yeah yeah but then what
if the video especially gets in like
recommended and starts really taking off
is when you start seeing the really
[ __ ] stupid comments
on trending on trending or if it starts
like if the views start climbing
really fast and then you start getting
the people who don't know who you are
right and it won't leave their record i
don't know how i got here comments
i don't know who this is
do you guys get like to have like a
honeymoon period with your videos where
you have like this after you finish like
a big project or something you like the
first two three days
you go through every comment you're just
reading it all the time and then it just
and then you kind of just don't care
about it anymore you move on i said
exactly well because because
youtube forces you to be like oh you've
you've secured cancer all right now cure
cure something else please that's like
it's it's like it's no matter what you
do it's never
that's a terrible analogy by the way
it's never good enough for you the
victory lap is always short right yeah
yeah like
it doesn't matter how big or how amazing
you did i mean like look at the
like unasanas that channel right like
they did like a whole year's worth of
content
deleted it it was a giant thing and now
they have to get on about it
yeah it's it's it's weird how it's weird
and scary how short
internet memory is crazy it's like unes
is was
an amazing concept an amazing idea and
it's like so impressive that they pulled
it off
like but how long is it gonna actually
remain in people's memories you reckon
it's it's gonna be tough it's hard to
say because there's
like basically all evidence of it has
been removed now
they wanted do you know what that is by
the way luckily so there's these guys
there's these two youtubers well
markiplier is one of them
they basically did a channel where they
uploaded daily and at the end of it they
were taking it all down yeah in latin
means one year
right so basically they would upload
every day for 365 days
and then on the 365th day they would
delete their channels and they did
interesting concepts yeah and then they
they take down any videos that are
reuploaded so the whole point of it was
to be like in the memory of the people
yeah it's quite cool
really cool but again it's one of those
things just like oh my god they pulled
it off the videos that long
and then now it's like okay cool now
what like
the only thing that remains now is like
just the merch that they released
throughout
being a youtuber and like making content
on the internet yeah well you know it
was always morbid because i was watching
casey neistat back when he was starting
to blow up and doing daily vlogs and
this man was literally sharing like
every aspect of his life
yeah and then it's still like but we
want more like what else do you have
show is everything and it's like this
man is literally like doing everything
the world has to offer
yeah youtube is like come on keep going
and then he stops and then you know
his channel didn't do very well for a
while didn't grow he took a break
because obviously you're gonna get
burned out from doing that oh yeah but
now he's back i think he's doing like
sparingly he seems to be happy yeah he's
pretty chill yeah that's crazy though it
scares me that what just having to do
that like
and that people i think my version of
hell is daily uploads
daily vlogs and then having to edit that
said daily vlog
it's not just daily vlogs it was like
highly produced yeah it was like
kind of like what you were trying to do
across japan the first one let's not
talk about that
i have to see daily sea dog va it would
just be like we'd just be sitting in a
chair like
me grumbling for like four hours playing
a video game and then just
doing nothing i'd watch that
you know what i'd be like in the room
with you be like wow
i've always i've always wanted you know
how you see those like those really like
shitty bbc like three documentaries
about like
unamusing things and like the youtuber
ones i really want like a like a bbc
four or something to come and be like
follow me for a day and just be like
yeah so i just kind of sit here all day
really and just chat
[ __ ] online i mean just however you've
been playing league for the past
uh what what now it's like oh maybe
another form we're gonna talk to
connor's going to go to the supermarket
and eat food like normal humans
and then go back to his house and eat it
but with that voiceover it kind of works
and maybe the kid what he could sell it
to me that's that's a good concept i
would
i really want to do something like that
just so i can like [ __ ] with the footage
constantly while i'm recording like put
this in keep that out
like about doing like daily videos just
for a week thing to try it out
that's scary that's a lot of work chris
you're not the editor
no but what would i do daily like would
it be like like the way that you did the
the fuji video where it's like go on a
journey
across japan
i was thinking perhaps transportation
across
japan
a different form of transport a bicycle
a skateboard a horse
i wouldn't watch that oh i feel like
we're building something
i feel like you shouldn't give me a
horse because i already call people
peasants
like unironically i think that'll raise
the bar you know what i mean
like fully dressed up like a princess
hello peasants
i actually actually uh drove across
japan not well not across church
i drove in in hokkaido recently and
that's pretty fun it's pretty relaxing
yeah it was really relaxing there was no
snow thank god oh wow but it was really
chill
it was nice i went for i drove from
toyaco
to uh what did i drive like sapporo
did you get in the bori betsy hot
springs ah i did stop there but i was
like
hot in it it's kind of like nothing else
here it's like japan's
like number three is it actually it's
like one of the biggest best
hot spring resorts in japan i was hungry
there was the go-to travel thing so i
saved a ton of money that's that's
insane so japan
inside of japan for domestic travelers
they were actually giving you 30 35
off your trip so hotel transportation
and then when you got to your hotel they
gave you vouchers as well
yeah yeah so yeah so to spend at like
the nearby like the towns like food
so i stayed in a place that was like 500
a night normally
and it was down to 300 and it included
like an eight-course gourmet meal
and it was like a private onsen and then
on top of that they're like here's 200
to spend which you can also spend to pay
on like stuff in the hotel which i was
like
wow that's that's epic that is
sounds very familiar because we got like
500 of vouchers or something one night
on jane across japan
and we spent it all in family mart oh
yeah that's all right yeah you can spend
it anywhere
because we had like one day to spend it
and you can you spend it in the same
prefecture yeah yeah yeah
because like four of us stayed in one
hotel room we got something what did you
buy
it's like a [ __ ] ton of booze and snacks
five hundred dollars worth
well yeah there's four of us it was like
a hundred bucks worth of i just couldn't
could you imagine something about
happening in the uk it would be [ __ ]
it would
it would be a [ __ ] frenzy if you told
people that 30 off plus get free money
to spend
the japanese government just went mental
with this and they're extending it now
as well did you see that oh god
they're extending it until like june or
something originally it was until the
end of
march right yeah but now it's until like
june july something like that which is
crazy
because stuff's already i think the
stuff is pretty cheap already here
travel wise
compared to the uk i didn't realize how
much japan's economy relied on tourism
until i moved to japan and i've
i've realized how how much people like
value tourism here yeah like traveling i
mean scary like
uh in like july uh miyanaki went up to
kyoto for our
anniversary right and i was dead yeah it
was scary i've never seen kyoto that
empty my life and we went on a week like
we went to
inaudible the the thousand times yeah
i've been there yeah
as well yeah on a weekend it was like a
saturday at like 1pm so normally
i would never go there on a weekend yeah
and when i when we went there was like
four people there yeah i went yeah i
went there as well as no one though oh
it's because of you telling me that yeah
a few weeks ago that i'm actually going
to
tomorrow oh really so i'm just going to
be walking around probably perfect
it was actually like a ghost town all of
kyoto i can't imagine going there now
when the country opens back up yeah like
the best experience being like oh kyo is
pretty chill isn't it
yeah no tourists no no nothing yeah that
was that was literally my impression of
it yeah and now that i like i've seen
pictures of what kyoto is usually like
and it looks like literally my health oh
it's ridiculous pretty much never want
to go back
like you on a weekend or like even a
weekday it's just shoulder to shoulder
people yeah
everywhere you go because like one thing
that really turns me off going anywhere
if it's like a big tourist
yeah i hate crowds and i hate you know
seeing seeing the
seeing the tourist selfie like five
people doing the same [ __ ] poses and
the same [ __ ] selfies
yeah i'd rather just like chill out at
my [ __ ] hotel at that point
yeah well now is the perfect place to um
it's a perfect time to go to like osaka
kyoto
all those people i just like being
[ __ ] lazy like on a vacation i don't
want to go to a
museum or anything like that why do you
want to do a kyoto connor
nothing absolutely [ __ ] not i'll you
know i'll i'll i'll do the obligatory
all right fine let's go and see the [ __ ]
and then for the other days you can see
the [ __ ]
go and see the [ __ ] i want to watch a
travel series with you in it it would
just be
i went to that like the thousand you
what i was what was it the thousand
shrine and i'm like oh it's
cool and i'm like when am i where are we
eating though
me and connor are exactly the same in
that size because yeah like
is it like when you go on a trip with
someone yeah and they bring out a
schedule i'm just like oh girls no no no
tell me the restaurants we're going to
yeah what are they specializing and also
are we gonna have at least four meals a
day if not i'm gonna have a problem
because when i travel i want four meals
a day
like i'm just gonna eat eat like i don't
i'm just an absolutely but you can do
that and also in between the meals you
can go
it's stressful it's stressful like i
want i want to go to a place and i just
want to have
no pressure to go anywhere yeah if i
want to go see something i will go see
something but like if
if i feel like i'm pressured into going
somewhere that just automatically makes
me
not want to go somewhere unless it's uh
this is a nice restaurant also it's like
it's vacation right i don't wanna
[ __ ] work
you know i i'd work walking places
going to see the shrine would you ever
consider being a tour guide for your
viewers
for the right price sure chris i'll i'll
i'll wait for the right price
oh yeah i don't mind i mean doing the oh
i can we can't talk about that yet okay
all right was the trash taste special
that was a nice view that we had
i could appreciate that but then also at
the same time it's like this is fun for
10 seconds
but then what are we eating yeah well i
mean let's be real like
like we probably would have not gone
there if it wasn't for to be fair yeah i
i
don't like for me when i go to a place i
don't remember what i saw or what i did
i remember what i ate
is that is that is why is that that's
not weird that's not weird
i mean i i i don't remember what i did
in hokkaido but i remember the meals
like vivid vividly i'm i'm kind of the
opposite i had a big fat crab and they
murdered that crab in front of me it was
delicious i i
i'm actually no christian added to the
flavor
i'm kidding as much as like you know i
love the food like especially in like
hokkaido you know wherever i am and
you know especially anywhere you go in
japan the food's always going to be good
right
but i don't know like i'm always kind of
the one who was like yes i remember
going here
here here i'm more of a location person
than a food person i'll just see like a
tourist thing pop up
oh i went there's but [ __ ] well maybe
that's
maybe that's the problem you're kind of
going into it with like a negative
mentality right i just want to eat
like so like what what is what is so
special about this place like i
i i think i grew up with it because any
time my parents would take me to this
place we'd like take take the tourist
picture oh my god yeah my parents let me
do that yeah and i'm just like i don't
[ __ ] care i just want to be in my
hotel room and play my [ __ ] game boy
yeah yeah yeah
sometimes you just want to chill in the
hotel room and just like get some food
and watch the [ __ ] just like
don't like traveling no i love traveling
but i hate doing tourist stuff
being in a new place i just don't like
actively going to
i like the environment i don't give a
[ __ ] about like
sports hot spots i want to meet i want
to meet people have i like chat
drink and just eat and chill i want to
do something active yeah
something active to me like going to a
place and taking pictures it's not like
an active thing that i enjoy like if
there's like an activity there
or something i could do then yeah great
i'll [ __ ] go well it's weird for me
because
i like i don't go to the locations to
take photos if anything i very rarely
take photos at tourist locations because
i feel that
by taking a photo of something it's like
the only thing you're going to remember
is
what's in the photo whereas like i want
to rem i want to actually remember
that's something right there then rather
than like
the opposite i just forget everything so
i need to have i do not really like
and that rekindles the memories i've
lost
with my trip to kyoto i've got no plan
though like going on what you guys been
saying like
this time i'm there for a week no plan
is it vacation are you filming
kind of half and half like i'm doing a
documentary on old
uh dilapidated kyoto houses that have
been redone and
whatnot that'd be really nice but like
really no plan
maybe just walk around and see what i
can kind of find yeah also i like the
feeling of discovery as well i like
going somewhere and
not knowing what i'm going to see if
it's like if it's all planned
and you know people have like researched
this place and i'm like i know a really
cool place because i've read up read
about it and everything
it feels less special than just like
driving around and seeing a cool place
and just being like
that sounds that looks cool you're
absolutely right like i
my um cousin came over last year to
kyoto we had like one day and we
literally just got in a taxi i was like
oh the king gakusha you go to the
fishing
aria we'll just do it went to all these
like five places it was all right he saw
everything got the photos but it wasn't
really any good
memories or experiences as a result well
i mean i i don't like
whenever i go somewhere i'm not the one
to be like all right
these are all the tourist locations
let's go here like i'm still very like
picky choosy on where i want to go
yeah because because to me it feels like
playing an open world game where you
have all
like the checkpoints like marked out
already well i like a breath of the wild
kind of
experience where i'm just like exploring
that place yeah i mean you do get that
in kyoto though like kyoto you really do
yeah like a video game you can discover
little shrines little restaurants oh
there's so many coffee shops there's so
many cool
well especially with kyoto i actually if
anything i avoid taking the trains
anyway
we always walk from one location to
another because
the walk along the way is where you find
all the cool [ __ ] yeah and then on top
of that you get to go to a tourist
destination so it's like
best of both worlds in my opinion
absolutely yeah like for me my ultimate
holiday or my ultimate tourist sport is
just put me in like a cool place and
just don't tell me anything about that
place and just
right
[ __ ] it was so hot in kyoto i remember
sweating my ass off though well
wednesday awful
it was summer like july or something
yeah we went there too it was
gonna die i did not like that did not
like japanese summer
it was as bad as everyone said it was
going to be but i thought everyone was
exaggerating
because like there's no way it can be
that awful but it was no it's pretty bad
i'm gonna open
this sake and have a bit of a taste test
so chris
what are your new year's resolutions for
this year to be on trash tastes
third time the first time a third time
after this after this wow well you are
the first guest of uh 2021
and the first reoccurring guest and i
got my
thing up on the wall i love you guys
especially
how do you feel with next or all these
like uh
a little more elaborate squishies i put
a lot more effort into this than i did
i looked like i was like scribbling it
the last minute before i got on a train
or something
new year's resolution get into shape i
think i say it every year
everything i mean that's like the most
generic year's resolution anyone could
uh are you actually going to though
i would i would do something really bold
right okay i'm going to say
i want to make natsuki famous
my good friend that's great i would
argue that natsuki is kind of already
like world level global tom cruise level
famous
is that possible how would you go about
doing something like that i think at
first you would have to get to that
point right
you said i'm not world famous wall frame
is chris
broad [ __ ] you now jerry that's a lot
isn't it jesus christ it just takes
longer to be in a hospital by the end of
this
oh for hers as well for him
is it smelling hers interesting fact
depending on how you drink sake like in
a cup or a glass it smells and tastes
differently
that's kind of like how it works because
if your your nose is over the glass you
get more of the scent
commonly commonly known
somebody's going to destroy me in the
comments he's wrong about everything
see how this tastes then chris if you've
got a [ __ ] taste so you've got the trash
taste
sorry
where they have to say the title of the
bond film every time
have you guys ever had a new year's
resolution come off here oh my god
it's good that costs like twelve dollars
twelve dollars
he's being a baby that's ex that's
expensive for psychedelic something
these samsung bottles like four bucks
no expense spared for you connor it
tastes like a sour barrel
so thank you chris that cultural
appropriation you're
disrespectful to the people who made the
sake
you disgust
it's not bad it's not bad it's just it's
i don't really drink like
strong liquor
i'm a bit of a little [ __ ] with that
stuff i won't lie i'll do a shot
reluctantly
but you know when we go out to yeah
cigar bar or whatever we'll
go yeah
oh my god chris come on so we'll go and
these boys will be like we have to get
whiskey because we're
civilized men you know and i'm like i'll
have the pinkest string that you have
and i have no problem with doing that
because i know what i like chris does
the drink name have the word [ __ ] in it
i'll have it
which one has glitter in it tell me that
have you brought out your own
like trash taste sucker yet all right
is that is that something you could hook
up for us chris do you know a guy you
know
can we make that a new year's resolution
for trash taste release of trash
the drink you could like choose what's
in the sake or the beer you could can we
actually do that with each person
yeah great christmas the most sucky
brewery that i have now
wow it might imagine we have what we
need we need to do that for a special
and have crispy
the chief taste tester i would be up for
that you wouldn't of course you could do
that
okay i've actually looked into like
crafting
my own beer and your own wine and
apparently it's illegal in japan
yeah apparently even though you can buy
kits
in japan but it's illegal to make it but
you can buy the kits well then what the
[ __ ] you do with the kids
you pop it up on the shelf it's like a
sake building kit
it's like they have like radios as well
like we did we got walkie-talkies
the laws in japan were really strict
with walkie-talkies given that you can't
use some frequencies
half the [ __ ] on amazon in japan is like
the illegal frequencies
and it's like why are these being sold
what good gods
did you get like police on it why are
you you could you could you might
accidentally get like the police like
picking you up you know it'd be like
the fbi would be pretty scary wouldn't
it so you're on the other end of it
or would you like to see your ass and
then a police officer police officers
like it
oh my god i was trying to ask this
earlier but have you guys ever had a new
year's resolution that you've actually
kept to
or like have you guys actually had a new
year's resolution i did actually have
one to lose weight and i did actually
lose weight that year how much [ __ ] you
chris
i'm kidding uh i think i lost
eight kilograms that year eight
kilograms yeah that's pretty good
oh was that the year where you should be
a little chocolate chicken and broccoli
yeah yeah
that's a bit of a chunker dude that's a
little bit of a chubby boy
though i like you know you were saying
like oh yeah i want to lose look at my
old videos
like i have old photos of you and like
you're in some of my old videos as well
and back then i was like no he's he's
fine he looks like a healthy way
but then i look at you now why are you
laughing at my meals chris
chicken and broccoli everything yeah it
was depressing it was [ __ ] awful
again
200 days
i pretty much just was like all right
the highlight of my day
was the protein shake which was somewhat
sweet i was like oh this is amazing
oh dude i'm chicken and broccoli in it
no
no sadly i would have my like chicken
broccoli
it would be like white chocolate protein
shake and it would not taste like white
chocolate and then i would go home and
be depressed and eat and cook [ __ ]
chicken
broccoli like the fifth time that week
i just imagine you're like in the
supermarket your trolleys just for
nothing
my roommate hated it because i it would
take turns cooking right
right so they would cook something and i
you know if it was if it was not very
good for you all right fine you know
but then i'd be like guess what where am
i having tonight
guess what i'm making tomorrow chicken
and broccoli it's the connor specialty
it's
steamed chicken and broccoli i think
that should be your resolution this year
on a daily basis for the whole year to
be fair
not not that difficult in the family
mark you can get those
chicken tikka breaks did you like mix up
the dish every day like one day was like
chicken and broccoli in a curry next day
no it was just oh my god it's literally
just
chicken and i would i would boil the
broccoli and i would chuck the chicken
uh
in the oven with uh with some like piri
piri like seasoning and that was it
every day
a sea dog va cookbook chicken cooked
first i feel so sorry for seeing a man
i mean okay it's it's like it's
tough because at the time i think the
problem is now is that i socialize
because i think when you actually social
when you actually have
friends that you go out with because in
the uk you don't actually go out that
much with your friends
like i think i think it's it's a bit of
an event in the uk it's more of like a
weekend
thing right but yeah yeah whereas moving
to japan especially as like you do in
the week a lot
yeah you go out during the week-long
even if it's just good to go out for
like a lunch or a dinner
yeah i think i meet people for lunch or
dinner at least three times a week now
yeah and like it's so hard to diet when
you're
going out and you're having lunches and
you know because normally when you have
lunch on your own you might have a
sandwich
you go to a restaurant to have lunch
it's always just it's so [ __ ] much
why why have you got that face
so if you don't socialize it's really
easy to just feed yourself [ __ ]
garbage and just like you'd be like all
right [ __ ] chicken and broccoli
yeah i mean in the uk you go out to me a
mate and it's either a sesh
or harder
and you [ __ ] kill yourself but if
you're at home you know it's really easy
to
just eat a lot of broccoli i could
probably eat chicken and broccoli
because peripery seasoning honestly like
yeah because like when you said like
chicken and broccoli i thought like no
like maybe like salt and pepper yeah
salt pepper yeah of course
or like some kind of like marinate then
it's a little better not much i would
buy this like pre-packaged garbage and
it would like
you would have to put it on the chicken
before you cooked it right and they
would say like
in the picture it looked like absolutely
coated but what would end up happening
is one
splodge of this chicken would have a
[ __ ] ton of seasoning and the rest of
the chicken was
bone dry because i just burnt the [ __ ]
out of it i got desperate the other day
and i was like really missing i was
really missing i was really missing
nando's i looked up
i looked up if there was like anywhere
you could import nando's source
it was like 50 quid for a bottle of
nando's sauce
and i i was just like
and i click the buy button i've never
felt so
disappointed about myself that i've
gotten to the point where i've spent
50 quid to buy a bowl of nano sauce how
much
how much sauce are we talking like it's
like it's it's like a medium bottle so
it's like
it's not even that big i was i was just
missing nando's so much i miss perry
perry man
i miss my periphery chicken how much
wealth is too much
it'll be worth it when you plop it on
your feed pop it on yourself
what's the chris broad diet then if
you're mocking my my chicken and
broccoli
you're just [ __ ] winging it just
every day you wake up you're like [ __ ]
it might have a
chicken tikka the only thing i can cook
is omelettes so it's either
or more or omelettes wait so what are
you what are you eating when you're
dieting
that isn't it just omelette every meal
you like it's like oh it's five o'clock
you know what time that is another
omelet
you can mix it up there you go like
cheese in it you can have chicken
you know you know would spice up an
omelette
chicken and broccoli take the trash
taste diet ladies and gentlemen
broccoli for a week you don't you don't
lose on chicken and broccoli chris you
just wait
you should try a chicken and broccoli
omelette next yeah i also i also uh
followed this strange youtube guy that
was like it was apparently this this uh
soup that would make you lose weight
because it would have negative calories
what um but you would have like mad fun
well essentially yeah because you would
put okay okay how would you have
negative calories so the ingredients in
it would actually make you
like were so like salary for example
right it was had a lot of celery in it
so you would end up actually took more
calories to
quote-unquote eat like digest it than it
was to eat it
really and i would make this giant thing
of it it was just a bunch of [ __ ]
vegetables like
onions cabbage like fine because you
would put like
uh onion um onion soup powder in it and
like a can of tin tomatoes so just taste
like a
shitty minestrone soup but you would
have like a giant [ __ ] bowl of this
[ __ ]
and you're like oh my god oh my god 20
minutes later your stomach is still full
but you're like i'm hungry
i'm so hungry and you're full but you're
like you're farting non-stop as well
it's
awful i couldn't stop farting and the
the comments on this video are all about
how people cannot stop farting
and about how it's causing problems
that's yeah that's that's what you use
all the calories for like for the
violent [ __ ] honestly
it was embarrassing i was on like the
train i i just every time i managed to
hold
one in 10 seconds later another one
would claw its way out
i was like sorry just give up and start
farting
because i was also trying to exercise as
well and there's nothing worse than
needing to fart while you're running
because how do you because when you're
where you shot
because because when you're sitting down
you can kind of like
you can engage your videos you can kind
of like you can kind of maneuver it out
you know
you know you can like like massage it
out
of your cheeks but you're farting when
you're running it's like do i just let
this boy come out at full speed
but then you realize the treadmill's so
[ __ ] loud that you're like just fart
away yeah no one's gonna care
disgrace disgraceful [ __ ] off british
gentleman
there's no way they'll hear because i'm
[ __ ] on the treadmill
well i've told you my new year's
resolution but like and you said like
is there a resolution you can keep the
only way is to do like become a better
person
keep it vague right and then you can
decide the parameters on the phone
if it's at that point then you might as
well just say stay alive
and become a better person eat food
i'm going to eat this [ __ ]
what's your resolution i never really
like made resolutions because
like i used to when i was little because
my entire family was i was like i guess
i have to make one too yeah but then
i don't think i've ever kept a
resolution my entire life
i don't know maybe maybe it's because
i'm too over ambitious with my
resolutions like what
the most resolution you've ever seen i
don't know
youtuber edition my top 10
ambitions my new year's resolution this
year is to do a video with chris broad
on my channel cheers but i don't know
what the [ __ ] to do with you chris
broccoli and chicken and broccoli
i brought in a pan with my spin-off
we challenge master chef with chris
broad
who makes the best omelette have you
ever heard of homeless before
it's gonna be great my real resolution
is to do
a life-changing event this year what
does that mean chris positive
something good something's positive
what's
what what counts as a life-changing
event
sounds really bad like breaking my arm
for fun but like
like making something or doing a
challenge like doing a really crazy
challenge
right it's like amazing and wow it's
very vague isn't it
please help me with the ideas in the
comments how about a race across japan
across japan race race to mount foreign
really big a really stupid and awesome
that will define me for the rest of my
life they'll definitely
that is my new year's resolution that's
like a [ __ ] massive goal because how
do you define yeah i was about to say
don't be
right too over talking about over
ambition
why not why not i'm i've only won this
year i want chris to have his own nhk
show
i want chris on tv but it's going to be
fun i want your own tv show
on your own tv show called are you
youtuber where you interview different
youtubers
i mean like a street interview thing
where you go after like random
foreigners in japan and go are you
youtuber
oh gosh i mean yeah i have a second ted
talk a second
if the offer comes up and it's like i
don't care if it's like youtube based or
anime based or i don't know
joey the university of tokyo needs your
help
we need anime to the expert
for our centerpiece ted talk i mean i've
seen so many tedx talks where i just
like
there's not a whole lot of like
educational value
it's just fun the problem with ted talks
in general is that they'll often propose
a problem the world's gonna end
and they'll make you depressed and then
you're kind of waiting for a solution
like well then they're like good luck
with that everyone and then the walk off
stage it's like
you've told us the problem great what's
the solution i don't feel like they
don't do that enough for a lot of ted
talks my favorite one is when they talk
about something for like 20 minutes and
they segue into the actual topic and
there's like three minutes left
those are my favorite ted talks but
that's what i've noticed right like a
lot of tedx talks are just kind of
let's get this person who's really
passionate about something and just make
them spew their passion for 15 to 20
minutes
well i think uh adam savage did a really
good one right yeah cosplaying love
letter to cosplay it was really good
that one was really good yeah
i haven't seen that one yeah it's it's
basically him just saying like yeah i've
been to
uh comic cons and comic conventions for
the past like 15 years and i've always
cosplayed at one of them
so apparently there was a i forgot which
one it was but there was like i think it
was like new york comic-con or something
where he cosplayed as um
uh no face from spirited away you know
in that one it's like a full-on costume
yeah and because the character doesn't
talk no one knew was him
until after the convention when he said
yeah that was me that's trippy and
everyone was like
but i talked to you and took a photo
with you what
that's pretty cool didn't brian cranston
cosplay as brian cranston from like
breaking bad like no no he liked like no
no he wore like a brian cranston mask
and like one of the comic cons and like
you know wore like the ball to white
yeah costume just walked around and no
one knew it was brian constance that's
right
we gotta cook jesse he's like wow you
don't really good
god that'd be cool i impressions my new
year's resolution is to
get a schedule for my uploads i think
good one
you've been saying that for the past two
years as long as i've known god there
has been a a
like mystical schedule somewhere that
exists in the sky
i mean i can relate to you what what
dictates your schedule because my
schedule used to be really chaotic
yeah right now like before okay so there
was my schedule before trash taste and
then after trash taste
and before trash taste i there was less
of a schedule but at least i could
guarantee hey i will make like at least
two videos a month and it will come out
and now it's just
okay i finished the video um i don't
know when the next video is going to be
and uh yeah it's i mean my personal
schedule
this year especially for the last six
months has been like way more chaotic
compared to my entire five-year career
and like youtube
you managed to get a schedule for trash
days in six months and you've been doing
your own channel for 13 years
you still can't get a schedule going oh
boy it's weird talking to joey and
connor and hang out with them and like
and hearing how you can be ahead of the
schedule
and have videos planned out ahead and
i'm just like what is this five head
move that i've never heard of before
i mean like that would just [ __ ] that
would freak me and stress me the [ __ ]
out if i
brought out a video and i had nothing
else ready yeah
welcome to my world joey yeah well
welcome to my world i don't know how you
two do it
like well the pressure's on to make the
videos count do you not feel like though
like the moment
like you can't enjoy your weekend or
whatever because sometimes you're just
worrying about like [ __ ] i've got the
video done
yeah yeah that that is that is a big
problem that i'm trying to solve
like i see you guys on weekends i'm just
like well these guys don't like stress
about making videos at all i i try i try
to
try try to take at least saturday and
sun and maybe sunday off but always at
least take one day off yeah
i don't do something yeah i normally
always fail i yeah i always try and take
at least like
two days off like it doesn't have to be
a weekend just any two days within the
week
just a day where i'm just not working on
a video not planning anything just
chilling doing hobbies or whatever maybe
i should just change otherwise
i mean like simpler videos like me just
reacting yeah chris
reacting to people reacting to chris but
here's the thing it's like
at least my personal goal for 2021 of
youtube is to be like a lot more
ambitious in my videos but the problem
with more ambitious why are you laughing
what do you mean like as in like videos
that take more
vibration to like actually film and kind
of construct and you know a lot more
like narrative based i guess that
requires a little more preparation than
just writing a script or
just flicking on a camera and starting
to talk right yeah um
but the problem is with that is that if
i want to also maintain a schedule which
i would like to
then i also have to plan things way
ahead of time as well
right so like as of right now i am like
about a month and a half ahead in terms
of videos
yeah i have like yeah i know right
that's my exact reaction like i [ __ ]
like the next video filmed and i've got
to edit it
yeah i've got like another two ready to
go but yeah i've already filmed like six
videos
that's just waiting to get edited
because i think hanging out with you
guys i've realized i've just kind of
normalized working every day and then i
realized that's just not normal
right and well but the thing is is that
like i'm also working every day but also
you know making content for the anime
man channel is not the only thing i do
now
you know i have like trash taste and i
have like my other hobbies that i wanna
you know you've been everywhere the last
few months yeah like you've collabed
with like everyone and their mum
over the last three months pretty much
joey again all right joey there
yeah even in my videos he's there yeah i
know everywhere
yeah so yeah so many people are like i
think i think
there was one week where you uploaded an
episode of journey across japan
and then i was i i also did a video on
the same day as well
yeah yeah and people like how is he at
home filming with
jack when he's on a road trip with chris
right now
how is he doing it did he like go back
home quickly and then like
join up again with chris
i would like to get more collabs into my
content that's another new year's
resolution i want to make
i want to shift my content that's more
friendly for collabs because like
i don't think i've i think i've done one
collab in my life
um and that's been pretty much it for my
entire time on youtube and that's just
because
my content doesn't really lend well for
collabs
because the only the only way i could
collab with fight is like if i could
have like a guest reviewer and
like the what i think when i see a guest
reviewer is like remember those like all
that guy with the glasses
i hate that review collabs where he's
just like hey here's an expert on the
subject and it would be like the most
awkward scripted joke to introduce them
and then they're not as charismatic and
it's yeah well i kind of
i've made those videos back in my day
where like
when i had like more of like the
scripted like rant type of videos yeah i
would always have like a friend of mine
come in being like
what are you doing here
i'm here to talk about it it's it's just
so
not it's that that's what
that was literally what it was like how
did this man get a youtube channel
how did he make it grow that's what i
wanted it was it was like it was the
most like unnatural like guy fierious
like i'm here now let's talk about
whatever you know
the worst parts the worst the worst ones
were when it was scripted as if
you both didn't know you were going to
be in this video
you know what i mean yeah it's the whoa
what are you doing here type of thing
you can make that funny but when it's
like a scripted type of like discussion
based video
there is no natural way to write that in
a script
i've always found it awkward and cringy
as far as yeah and that's why i stopped
doing it because i look back at those
videos i'm like oh that was a mistake
right i shouldn't have done that and i
guess like i've been in plenty of
collabs this year and i kind of realized
this is this is kind of fun i want to do
this thing i'm the same i
i didn't really collab much if you were
the first person i did a collab with
them the original journey across japan
oh yeah
and you got a bit of hate for it yeah
because like you know at first your
viewers are like
who's this person in your videos they've
kind of broken into the world right they
always feel like it's nice
especially when it's another youtuber
yeah another youtuber but this time
there was nothing like that everyone
loved you
because it's been accepted and i do
quite like doing
collabs now it's quite fun yeah you
still have to find the balance of course
you have the right you have to find the
right the right situation yeah yeah
sometimes like you you take a look at uh
sometimes like i've done so many collabs
in my time where i've kind of figured
out like
just because you're friends with a
particular youtuber and just because you
guys can you know
supposedly talk about whatever in your
off time it doesn't necessarily mean
that they can be in
any video you want on yeah yeah and i
typically wait until i've known that
person
like a year yeah yeah exactly you've got
another a year [ __ ] chris
i've got i've got a calendar on my wall
which is countdown to collab with chris
maybe a new year's resolution for 2022.
your new year's resolution for 2021 is
get friendly with chris you also at the
end of the day it's kind of awkward
right if uh like you bring a
non-stop bunch of guests off and what if
they're just more entertaining than you
they're like like constantly like every
single guest you know everything
right it's like that's the other thing
like you if you hang out with a person
enough and that you know you especially
work in the same field you kind of get
the idea of like okay this is
their video right yeah like you can't
outrun it's like a
unspoken etiquette right i mean like i'm
not gonna like you know
because i did my best to not you know
[ __ ] take too much of the spotlight
away from chris because i'm like my
spotlight
because i'm like this is crazy like i
understand this is chris this channel
this is his show
and i was like that in your video when
you did the capsule hotel yeah right
shipping container yeah and i was just
like i'll just
because you're watching the hammer you
just kind of like follow you kind of
follow their lead right because
they're going to do the over-the-top
intro or whatever yeah right right so
like you kind of just have to learn that
through
experience you just got to be the you
just got to like
be subscribed no no no no no no no no no
no no
no no
no no no no no no no no no no no be the dog
that you are
[Music]
i'll go oh your place yes
yeah i don't know shall we get naked and
in the bath now we're doing a shot
and you're going to like it that's kind
of like what it was
a where is he
yeah i don't know like i i also want to
i also want to keep doing collabs as
well but i kind of again you're the
collab king
yeah and i look at it i look good
supposedly people i know who have done
collaborations with more youtube you all
like
probably done it more than anyone yeah
who doesn't say
no right i i don't know i just i don't
know i just have like uh
i i feel there's like a totally
different quality of doing a collab
regardless of what the content might be
right
like in my opinion if someone told me
okay you can make a youtube channel and
you can have all these millions of
subscribers with millions of views
but you can't collab with anyone right i
kind of be like what's the point that's
[ __ ] lie
that's a [ __ ] off because
[Laughter]
like if i did an entire year worth of
content just by myself
it wouldn't be fun it would i i would be
like it's not fun but
i'm still getting paid [ __ ] it i'll do
it i'm going to be honest
the suck is hitting and i don't know why
we got to finish the ball
it's delicious what can i say nearly
finished
it's like it's like drinking [ __ ]
paint cleaner straight from the barrel
shouldn't just be you connor shouldn't
have yeah if you want to be friends with
chris
chris probably you probably bought too
much and you were like [ __ ] let's
unload one on the boys
[Music]
i know i know you have the british
mindset i know how it is with gifts
come on it's a last minute thing and
you're like oh [ __ ] it over twelve
dollars
i'll pay you twelve dollars to not bring
it next time
send it back to get me something else
get me a wine okay then like who saved
like gone
uh chris like who is like other than the
people you already know who is
a youtuber that you would want to
probably collab with the most well i
mean chris you have to say my name that
quickly i mean come on
it's a really difficult question i don't
like is there a title or like maybe not
a particular person but like is there a
type of youtube susan orgisky maybe
i couldn't believe it that was really
weird that was surreal that i couldn't
believe that either
and also youtube the actual official
youtube channel commented on our video
when we saw mount fuji saying
congratulations oh was that on our video
i don't even know youtube had an
official
i thought it was the fukushima video
that they commented that no they
commented on
us oh no that was yeah that was susan
but yeah yeah youtube official channel
right and we saw fuji like well done
lads and i was like is that someone hell
yeah
youtube has an official channel with 35
million subscribers
good luck damn thanks youtube thank you
now stop demonetizing my content
yeah i don't know who i'd want to collab
with i i feel like if i knew who i
wanted to collab with
i i'd you would have started by now yeah
i'm like i i need to figure out what
what content i would want to do first
because
the thing i hate the most is seeing
collab content that's
super very obviously like very forced
collab content
desperate um like in your in your recent
one
it makes sense to have someone else
there to play off of right and yeah
sorry yeah i'm right here this guy
i mean joseph unfortunately i i refuse
to say his name since uh he took my spot
chris promised his spot for me and then
joey came in and swooped it away i
couldn't believe it the audacity
i'm kidding oh you [ __ ] it oh wow
oh it's this wine bottle opener this is
this is the one dollar [ __ ] wine
bottle opener for daiso
oh you didn't need to drink that anyway
oh that's that's the wine out the window
it gives it a more earthy texture anyway
this is good wine as well i [ __ ]
picked this out i used to work at a
castle and i did that an awful lot
when i was serving guests at a castle
what was the car what's significant
about the castle
hold on a second you worked at a castle
or which castle yeah i mentioned
when i served uh prince andrew and elon
musk what
not the same night that'd be mental but
like what wait how was
how how is this the first i'm hearing of
this yeah
this is the first time hearing over this
from me please please stop the sucky
talk
come on i worked at a castle on elon
musk which castle
i can't
and i had to bring out his um rocket
shaped birthday cake
did he does he also have a lightning
mcqueen bed at home
did he rock up with just the biggest
blunt in his hand
well yeah i know yeah he did but i
they did he did no defamation here oh oh
oh oh oh oh no it's breaking
grab it by the hand this is this is so
tense
so i i i did see chris that there was a
japan
times article that heavily featured you
which is discussing
the reaction videos about japan yeah
what's their japan times article yeah
that was the japanese
first time i really heard about it for
some reason since september there's been
about 25
reaction videos for in japan from
primarily japanese
uh youtubers i know i i didn't know that
i thought there's like two or three then
i read the article
mm-hmm what japan is with they felt that
was a topic right right
i'm great they did thank you japan times
but it they they were like
it's becoming really popular i think
people are getting really interested in
hearing what japanese people think of
foreigners living in japan and kind of
reacting to it
but then when you ask them they're just
like i don't [ __ ] care yeah they're
just like they're there
i think people want it to be a lot more
interesting than it actually is yeah
and i've watched a few and that's the
thing i'd be more inclined to hear what
a japanese person would think if they
were actually giving
you know an opinion but they're not
they're usually just like i mean there's
someone who doesn't really
understand why reaction videos are good
i found it quite difficult to grasp
and i've watched a few and you know
because they're japanese they're very
nice and kind and polite
british they'll be like this guy's a
prick yeah what are you talking about
but i would argue that's more of an
interesting content right like at least
you get to hear someone's opinion
whether it be
positive or negative rather than just
you know like on the fence type of like
oh yes yes this is a video indeed it's
just if someone watches your video and
they're silent and they get a million
views
there's something about that that's like
okay
but like one guy did do that yeah yeah
yeah he's just he's just going
it's just me saying something like don't
do this it's literally just a million
people he's going for
an anime reaction so like how many
videos does your original video i mean
how many
how much sake have you had i mean let me
rephrase that how many views does your
original video have
so i i don't actually know i think it's
like 10 million views it's ridiculous
it's the 12 things 12 things to do in
japan and it's like 10 million views
that is the one they have been reacting
to most i think
right yeah because i find that like i i
have like a few
like videos that people react to as well
and for some reason like
all of them just blow up like compared
to like any of my other videos they all
like do amazingly well
so i feel like you know it's it's weird
seeing someone react to your videos
especially especially if it's just like
okay
and it's i don't know how so i i assume
you've watched people react to your
videos like two or three and
they're all right they're nice they're
great respectful one
the one that i did of the one i think
the most successful one that's got
millions of views
it's weird someone's got millions of
like views uh
millions of views reacting to my video
it's that's kind of surreal but
how do you feel about them possibly
making you know a few thousand dollars
off of that
i don't really mind to be honest i'm not
that bothered
i'm curious because every other creator
tends to have a different kind of how
would you feel about it
and you've probably had that i've i've
had that ah i can't remember if i have i
don't think i have but i think it would
probably
i'm just clearly not interesting enough
chris you're
truly broccoli i mean it's i guess
again i wouldn't do anything but i might
just like muscle
i might be like oh i think if they're
funny
i'll be like cracking that's fantastic
but if they're just kind of like like
you said just kind of um
agitated one of them the main one the
guy's got the most views
nice bloke he uh disagrees with my
number one point
on my what to do in japan number one
point is
don't walk down the street in japan and
eat and drink while you're walking
it's not like a law right you're gonna
get arrested for doing that yeah but
people will be like just like social
education people look at you and be like
what the [ __ ] are they doing yeah like
yeah because
in japan there's not that many like you
never see anyone like
or trash cans
in the street right and so you don't you
know you can't throw your stuff away but
like
there's a reason why the streets of
japan are so clean they're very clean
and yeah people don't tend to
eat and walk but this guy's like oh no
we do do that in japan and osaka you can
do it and it's like osaka is different
and in downtown osaka you can do it
because lots of stands for like takoyaki
yeah
fried octopus street food culture it is
but that's only really an osaka
there's not many other places yeah like
you can do that maybe asakusa
in tokyo but in north japan if you do
that people will be like yeah i i do
foreign
i will admit i do do it when i'm in a
bit of a rush but it's like in the room
sometimes yeah chris i'm breaking the
law what am i going to do disrespecting
the culture
as always listen sometimes i got to be
somewhere and i i need [ __ ] food and
i
haven't got time to sit here and give a
[ __ ] about like standing in the family
mart depressed and eating it i'ma
[ __ ] walk and
shove it down my throat why are you
laughing chris
it is how it is what you just described
is something i do like every week see
them there in the
in the family mart looking out the
window like caged animals like
just wishing wishing they could walk
free
and eat their chicken but sadly they
can't
but like yeah i think that was the only
point you disagreed with and it made the
video feel a bit redundant
yeah yeah i feel like if there's
something like oh he's a foreigner in
japan he's right
yeah he doesn't know what he's talking
about maybe he's not good because he's
not japanese you know
if you just say well that's not what
they do start any any problems online
but yeah i'm thinking of doing like a
react video to the react videos in a
reaction video please don't react
that would be amazing those are always
the funniest i've got a headache just
saying it out loud
but it would be like inception of
reaction and i've got like 25 videos
that i can go through you have to do it
now because you've said it yeah yeah
that will get a million views yeah that
would be a lot yeah a lot of views what
would i kill the video
chris reacts to being reacted to chris
these people reacting to chris
yeah that's that's the most confusing
thing that's amazing because you see
that in your sub box you're like well i
have to watch this this is a [ __ ]
mess i think i think felix did i think
felix did that a while back where he did
uh
pewdiepie reacts to uh it was like
one of the fine bros episodes of them
reacting to pewdiepie
yeah and then sometimes feinberg has
even gone far enough to show that
and do like four four levels of
reactions
it's like a reply chain for me it's just
like the lowest form of content isn't it
in some respects
go for it every reaction
yeah i don't know when i look
[Laughter]
but i feel like it's very much like as
someone who spends
way too much time trying to make their
bloody videos as you know as well
to see someone just watch my video be
like oh [ __ ] it's good
yeah you know they get a million views
just like ah [ __ ] sake why would i
bother like
why don't you do that maybe i should be
around youtuber
and then you try it and you just like
drink sucky i'll be really bitter and
angry and i'll swear those would be
brilliant
i mean that'd be hilarious to watch
personally let's do it live let's do it
now let's do it don't do it
trust me chase reacts yeah connor let's
see
what am i dancing away
did you like my content did you like my
paul dancing chris
it's you three such interesting trio of
characters you've got
gant he does these slickly produced
videos
and then you've got joey's at the
forefront of otaku culture and anime
i love how you slipped into your abroad
in japan voice there yeah
right yeah yeah yeah there's a
difference look at these
three youtubers one glass of stuff my
guess my channel is the throw [ __ ] at
the wall and just make
and make it all stick if not glue it
back on if it falls off
three very diverse kind of characters
three diverse topics
i mean i feel like this year trash taste
has pretty much been the only
big thing that's happened to me last
year [ __ ] yeah
we're not filming this in 2020 sorry
this is being being
produced live apparently
only hours after recording this
what is the new year's episode without
the host getting like belligerently
drunk you know
what a great introduction to 2021 it's
just four pieces
i'm not seeing enough connor into
drinking stuff let's turn it from a
discussion to a [ __ ] just
bar conversation if i wasn't just
[ __ ] shouting at each other i'm not
gonna lie half the time i've forgotten
okay
like what do we even have a topic at
this point we're just chatting [ __ ]
we're just literally chatting [ __ ]
it's the shittiest episode sorry chris
do you have a topic no fantastic
all right why don't you like anime chris
what's up with that
i've got nothing i like anime is great
why do you hate people who like anime
the thing with anime is i watch it and i
go that's good
no the same way a dad sees his son's
hobby that's like
that's fine do it go up he's good but i
don't know where to go from there i
don't know what's the next level so
you're saying if we give you a detailed
guide on how to watch anime you will
then go ahead isn't that what we were
supposed to do in the first night yeah
there's a bunch of [ __ ] what do you
get from anime that you don't get from
live action
kind of films sakuya ever heard of that
word no
no why were you saying that [ __ ] what
because that's
because that's like trying to explain
what a jupiter is your parents you know
oh yeah that's true that's true
because right you know japan has a few
tv options right for example
they have you know this amazing anime
with incredible animation voice acting
really crazy plots or
or of course you can watch 24
the japan remake did you know that's a
thing
oh i heard about it it's brand new
they're it's airing now and it's
no no no no actual live action they're
completely remaking but i think in their
own plot 24
but just japan you know what it's called
it's called 24
japan that doesn't really work it
doesn't matter
and it's pretty bad you've watched it
yeah i watched an episode and it was
as [ __ ] as you thought it like really
low budget oh it's
like it's japanese jack bauer yeah yeah
yeah the entire cast the entire cast is
japanese i just think a jack bauer
personality s doesn't really work no
no not in japanese just fine japanese
tvs very low budget like trash taste
probably has a bigger budget
tv show i don't know about that we
haven't got a guy reacting can we have
chris's face whenever
everyone there is that's why you hate
react channels because that's most of
like japanese tv
you need a react cam in the corner right
absolutely someone going
i i was watching i was watching um who's
that really famous
uh comedy and also director guy in japan
he's
always on that billboard and shibuya um
i saw him and he was on japanese tv and
he was reacting to this thing and it was
like lgbt
stuff he had never seen such minimal
reaction in my life he was like a
bulldog just like
well yeah and then it cut to a guy in an
onsen giggling and he was like
and i was like well i think i know what
he likes
i don't care for this nonsense get that
off you know it was
it was just funny he was just like why
why there's like eight hosts and they
refuse to take the camera off him it was
just let's keep
him i think that'll take you to those at
the point where he's done
as long as he's on the show people it
doesn't matter it's just the main brand
yeah it's name so do you want to explain
to the audience who i guess like you
start talking she all beat takashi as
he's called okay she's casting yeah is
he's founded takeshi's castle and that's
where name comes from but originally he
was a japanese comedian and he's
basically the reason why
the whole she's crazy all right what are
you doing
i'm trying to talk about the taxi you
[ __ ] that is drink this up
anyway sorry i mean anyway so yeah so
he was like he basically founded the
whole japanese comedy scene back in the
70s
and he's the big reason why there was no
comedy before him
not in tokyo really yeah no no jokes
allowed no so in the so
the hallway he invented
no so okay so
so in in so the whole idea of like
manzai stand up comedy which is a very
like japanese form of stand-up comedy
where it's like you know
one like [ __ ] giggling at everything
like just shut up for a second
just like so basically like the whole
it's called monze which is like there's
usually one mic in the middle and
two people standing in front of one mic
you know doing a whole comedy routine
and that was really big in osaka or like
in kansai
region and the stand-up comedy well yeah
it's a little bit different to just
stand up comedy because a lot of
stand-up comedy at least in the west is
usually like
one person yeah right like it's just one
person kind of telling an anecdote
and then throwing a joke within the
anecdote right like that's
you know very general stand-up comedy
but manzai is kind of like that
but if you split the anecdote and the
jokes into two different people
so basically there's one guy who sets up
the joke and then there's one
yeah who throws the punch line and then
the guy who sets up the joke reacts
to the joke and it's that whole dynamic
is it like two-person rakugo
uh essentially yeah so like rakugo is
more similar to
western stand-up comedy in that sense
because dakugo is all about like telling
an anecdote and then throwing in a
punchline at the end rakugo just seems
like stand-up comedy hard mode
because like imagine stand-up comedy but
you have to sit in this one place and
you can't move and you have limited like
body movements right exactly but like
rocky goes like so [ __ ] ancient in
japan like
it's been doing it since like i don't
even know how long but it's very very
all formal comedy but basically
the whole manzai type of comedy really
originally started in like the 50s and
60s
but basically that was only really a
scene that existed in all sucker and
that's why like a lot of
comedians they're all famous they're all
from all suckers i've noticed and they
all speak in kansai dialect
right and but uh beat takeshi and his
group he was in
he was in a duo called tsubito and he
was basically the first
like really big manzai act to make it
big in the tokyo scene
and it was because of his success that
manzai moved
to tokyo as well and like the tokyo area
so that's why he's kind of just known as
like
yeah he's basically the godfather of
like tokyo monsters he's also a very
good director and actor
fireworks yeah yeah yeah they put me in
ghost of the shell movies
the dude's done everything like he like
paints he directs he's
like he develops his own game was he in
the original battle royale
yes oh yeah of course yeah that was one
of his biggest roles yeah he's pretty
good in that
he's really good he's a great actor yeah
he's a very funny while i'm just [ __ ]
eating chicken and broccoli every night
not achieving anything
where's your memory where's my mind's
eye i didn't realize he was a comedian
that's yeah he's originally because i
already know him as like an actor
director
he's quite weird because he's comedian
but he's also this incredibly stoic
very yeah i noticed yeah yeah whenever
you film he's very like
not called expression i can't imagine
him being a comedian because
er in every film he's played he's like
super serious super
right right like yeah you watch you
watch some like old like 70s footage of
him while he was still in tsubito and
he's just the most he was actually the
guy who
was like responsible for like telling
the part of the joke so he was always
the like kind of the clown on the show
right so it's really weird now watching
like ghosts in the show watching this
like
hard face seriously yes i am the badass
in this movie
just [ __ ] going around be like yeah
i'm the clown it's just
i don't know i find it really cool do
you like the movie
um likes a strong word okay
okay i liked it as [ __ ] i liked it if it
wasn't a ghost in the show movie right
why is it [ __ ] chris so boring
original anime film right that's what
i'm saying as a ghost in the show movie
it was really bad
but as a just a stand-alone like sci-fi
movie it was okay
i thought it was i i literally walked
out of the theater
really yeah because did you yeah i was
very unbritish of you
or just because you're like bored i was
just so bored i was really bored it was
it wasn't i haven't watched it it wasn't
good it obviously wasn't good but it
wasn't
offensively bad so what's the what's
like premise the film by the way for
like i have no [ __ ] clothes
i i know ghost in the shell but i
haven't it's basically the first movie
but with a bit of a twist
what do you know about ghost in the
shell i've watched all of standalone
complex okay so you
you basically know the best parts of
ghost in the shell okay
don't worry about the movie it's just a
really standalone complex smash it into
two hours and take away
all the interesting things okay and you
walk down huh and you walked out of that
yeah well how far in where you walked
out oh i was like did you get to like
the the first fight scene like with the
invisible guy
yeah yeah i got like 45 minutes before
i realized i'm like i'm about to fall
asleep now yeah
yeah that's that was probably the first
45 minutes was probably the best part of
the movie
the seats are comfortable though the
second half the way that the movie just
ended where they were just kind of
throwing in the whole like cultural
thing was just [ __ ] i feel like
scott
hansen was very well cast no actress but
like not not for that role yeah no
are you like i really respect scarlett
johansson as an actress but she just
really she it felt like she didn't care
at all it was like no acting like no one
really gave a [ __ ] it's like i get you
you're supposed to be a cyborg but
you know yeah put put a little bit more
she did that a bit too well
like sorry director when so you're a
robot right now and she's like
say no more i got it
i understand yeah i don't remember much
about that movie which is
i told you i've only walked out of one
movie uh in the cinemas and that was uh
dragon ball level who shows
see what's that in cinemas i would not
walk out of that movie i would be like
i would be having a great time watching
dragon ball whatever i thought so too
because i watched the trailer and i was
like god this looks like [ __ ] i'm gonna
go watch it
and then it was so much more boring than
i thought it wasn't even like
it wasn't like the so bad that it was
good level it was just really
i thought it was [ __ ] hilarious i
think it's hilarious wait chris have you
walked out of a movie theater
i've never walked out of a movie theater
this is the only one there was one
i just stopped caring really about like
very close
that's life in general downsizing with
the oh my god man david that's a
terrible film
that is an aeroplane i couldn't work out
what was going on if it was a comedy it
was a drama
it was just it's all over the place okay
but like how many times have you been to
the cinema by yourself
uh a lot i used to go all the time yeah
you should go like once a week in london
because like if you're seeing a film
with mates like you can't yeah you're
there
for better or worse even if your mates
drag you to this shitty [ __ ] adam
sandler comedy
like whatever yeah i mean okay one i
would watch this shitty adam sandler
movie but
uh i mean if i've planned to do it it's
normally in the evening and i want to
admit that my evening was
was tarnished by this film because i'm
still to enjoy the popcorn no matter
what right like and
maybe i get a little nap in as well i
text my feed my mates tell them about it
i'm [ __ ] it thanks chris being like
chris we'll be clapping this film sucks
dude i don't know like
i i i rarely go to cinemas anyway so
why i love cinemas i love them yeah it's
just something nice and relaxing and
when you
especially in japan like in the uk
people just throw popcorn and it's a
[ __ ] mess i mean this is
horrible popcorn's so good in japan as
well like less rarely films that i think
yeah
i need to go see this now no i don't
think that was any of the films i
watched i just think like
i want to go to the cinema because i
want the partnerships you just want the
experience
and i like the experience i like sitting
down like a tenant i did
yeah i really wanted i haven't seen it
now is right nothing
well i mean it's special considering
there's nothing out right now
i thought it was nice i'm not watching
the demonstration
if i understood japanese then i would go
to the cinema
so much more often right because i love
watching anime movies
because i'm actually in they have tons
of foreign films though
so this is going to be the worst
transition in the world because we were
just talking about films
but off camera questions hold up hold up
wait wait first of all before we
transition into that we should
finish talking about tenant or some [ __ ]
tenno it's all right seven out of ten
oh no no done done so chris just told us
how he ate a bear
last week i wasn't like walking through
the forest that went oh it's a bear i'll
get my knife a fork out and eat it
in in aomori north japan they bears
because it's too much
actually there's too many i've eaten
beer before how was it what does it
taste like
not good a part of me feels sad but then
why why would i feel sad about
other animals i don't know i don't know
about you did you have it as like a
proper dish
i could yeah i like cooked it on a grill
oh cause i had it in it i can
that sounds that sounds unbearable
wait wait how is it is it just very
gamey it's very
it's very fatty it's firm
it's like beef that's why did you make
the wood firm sounds so disgusting it's
like no it's a beef that's very hard
it's like chewing on leather essentially
like
any reason where did you get this from
you can get in the supermarket
what yeah i mean you you underestimate
like how many different types of trades
it was
it was also like i was in hakodate they
were just selling whale
yeah in like canada and that's very
controversial obviously
you can you can get like dolphin yeah
i mean because it's on one half it's
like you don't want to be like
hey japan stop doing that because it's
you know it's your culture yeah but on
the other half
please stop killing whales yeah well the
dolphins on the subject of bears
there's a lot of bloody bears that run
wild and go into towns
especially especially at the moment
because a lot of the rural population is
going down
and towns are actually becoming quite
empty especially in places like tohoku
and bears are like oh there's nobody
there i'm going to get in i'm going to
get a piece of the actually
i think that's sort of then the hunters
come shoot them they're like well we
could just leave it for dead or we could
eat yeah and then they sell it i think i
saw a piece of news the other day
whereas like i think this year there was
like the most amount of bear attacks
in like the last like 10 15 years or
something but in hokkaido they have
brown bears
on the mainland we've just only got
black bears which are kind of small yeah
not they only eat like for
people clearly vegetables carnivorous
bastards they are those bears
but the brown bears in hokkaido they'll
just [ __ ]
when i was driving i saw a bunch of
signs you didn't see anybody i didn't
see any but there were signs everywhere
like three years ago like 20 people
camping on hokkaido and a bear just
turned up and ate everyone
and everyone everyone they all died the
beer had a [ __ ] feast
lucky bear how does it how'd you defend
yourself from a bear attack in japan
because at least in like america you
people can carry guns there's a sprite
that's a thing that's a big does that
work does it work does anyone know like
pepper spray for beers but i think by
the time the bear gets so that close
you're already kind of [ __ ] yeah
because the baby's gonna be like oh i've
got my sprays
if a bear hits you you're dead yeah it's
not necessarily
not not if chris is there chris broad
here i read it i
read an article that uh there was a bear
turned up on a
uh oh an orchard in aomori with lots of
apples and they were like just doing the
orchard you know what you do like a
farmer
and a bear just turned up i was like ah
and this old man just went
and just punched it in the face the bear
was like [ __ ] just ran away
so you came back if you've got a
defender yourself against a bear just
punch it where is chris broad punching a
bear video
i was that's i i want to raise the level
this year
i did say that would be a
you know they're nice because obviously
you know to i think
it's hard because i think a lot of
audiences would see that and would be a
bit put off
and it's kind of hard to i guess there
are a lot of things like that where it's
like you do want to kind of be like well
this is what they do
and this is how they've always done it
it's almost like who are you to say they
can't do it but at times again
it's like the whale stuff right it's
like yeah it's pretty iffy it's a
difficult subject i had whale once to
know to never have oil again like it
doesn't it doesn't even taste good no
it's cruel isn't it that's why you see
that i felt so [ __ ] i was like well
you know
i was served at an eight o'clock what
was that and they're like oh as well i
was like oh
i feel very sad now i hated knowing what
it was and i was just like i don't even
even like the [ __ ]
because i can't even get behind it
anyway what is it like most countries
have agreed to stop it and japan just
like
japanese traditional food it's not that
popular in japan the reason it still
does well is the uh the politicians in
power they're aries
for whale to get voted it's all rather
political it's not because people
actually
normally have it yeah a lot of the older
generations do
like yeah because a lot of them like
grew up eating it after world war
ii is it the same thing with dolphins i
would assume
do they eat dolphins in japan no yeah
they do only in wakayama i think in that
little neighborhood
so sad they're such happy creatures
japan eats a lot of weird food yeah it
does feel like they're just
you know they just go through like the
the [ __ ] little mermaid and just like
i'll have that
but i think most people i don't i don't
think i've met anyone who's
eaten dolphin before i've never eaten
dolphin but it's pretty good
which is why when that documentary came
out um was it called uh
you know japan got loads of hate yeah
most japanese people like oh we don't
even
know what we don't need dolphin what and
they were surprised as well
you know you never see it in tokyo right
little fishing community
i've seen it being sold before but i've
never i've never known anyone who's
actually
eaten it enjoyed it it's very very easy
to stamp
you know a country together really
unfortunately i mean japan is quite huge
and and all the all the different
prefectures do feel really different to
each other yeah absolutely they have
like their own like
special threat right right you go to
every different prefecture and you're
like what's the specialty here
and i i like living in japan i kind of
like understand
gift culture a bit more here because
like everywhere you travel to there's
something unique
yeah famous for its wine yeah exactly
there's something unique about every
place you go to
and i don't know if they've just like
five-headed like the tourists
kind of gift i'm pretty sure they have
yeah yeah but it
you know it feels good to like come back
from a place and actually have a
souvenir that's unique you can only get
it in that prefecture right yeah
we've we've all been to like this kind
of country or this place where you're
like
you feel like you have to get a souvenir
just to get a souvenir and you get like
the most
tacky little [ __ ] keychain or
something like that right would you like
a fridge magnet yeah yeah
exactly i i do feel like in the uk i
don't know did you ever do
souvenirs i never [ __ ] brought
souvenirs back but i feel obliged to
hear
rocky candy yeah
it's like just this sugar like it it
has the like i guess the structure of
rock
but it's just sugar and you just [ __ ]
just it just sounds like a lump of sugar
british people don't have teeth
that's why like compared to other places
tourism in
the uk like within the so [ __ ] it's just
like it's non-existent
it's [ __ ] butling because that's all
it is like you go to one city
and it's like okay here's his c and then
you go to another c
it's exactly the first i want to visit
every weather spoons in the uk like what
are you gonna do in the sea oh let's go
to the pub what are you gonna do in
newcastle oh let's go to the pub where
you're gonna live in liverpool oh let's
go to the pub you know it's
it's it's to be fair that's me in japan
but i mean japan has a really strong
tourism industry because people don't
want to travel overseas a lot of the
time
yeah and there's a lot quite a lot of
population japan don't actually have
passports
and they don't have much time for
holiday holiday leaves really bad it's
all the work culture people have much
choice they do want us they just stay
here and they travel the country so
domestic tourism in japan is really
big business and each place has their
own unique thing so you can sort of
cross the board and be like well it's
really different in the next kind of
prefecture yeah i did notice when i
stayed in the ryokan that i
parked uh and there was tons of cars um
i was i stayed two nights right
but when i went there every single car
in this car parked left
so clearly everyone was only staying one
night which was odd most people only
stay one day
i've noticed that they stay one night
and then they're like done but i was
like nah i want multiple days of this
you kidding me well it's probably
because like a lot of them you know with
the whole work
work culture thing they're just right
you can't talk having more than two days
off is like a luxury right i think i
read a statistic that most people in
japan
take half their holiday leave i have 20
days they only take 10.
crazy yeah why is that do you reckon
because your boss your boss will be like
you've abandoned the team how dare you
you know
it's pretty what then when i was a
teacher like it was it was pretty it
could be quite stressful taking holiday
leave right
even more ridiculous one time i took
like three days off and they're like
okay and i have to get signed by a
supervisor and then the
headmaster the headmaster's mum they'll
have to sign it and then
i decided actually i don't need that
holiday i'll just stay and i got really
angry like what
you want to stay now don't do this again
you're not allowed to do that
i don't know why maybe it's because they
had to get teachers to look at like do
my job for me and i had to do sort of
things but
i don't know but like taking holiday in
japan is not fun and you're lucky
you work for trash taste as a result we
don't work we don't work for trash
tastes we are trustworthy
we are the system
a bigger t-shirt we are trash talking we
are trash tastes i'm wearing the trash
teach t-shirt
because remember working in the uk i
mean you you feel pressured to
take all your holiday they like kind of
like if you have any holiday
days left over that's like well
you can take that that's just free time
off why you're not taking it here it's
like
the complete opposite and i'm not sure
if it's the same in other asian
countries i feel like it would be
less of a pressure than it is in japan
because
work culture in japan is just seen as
letting down your team and if you do
take holiday leave you're less likely to
you know get that promotion
yeah you know if youtube worked for my
company you decided to take all your
holiday leave like you can
legally be entitled to yeah but you
don't i'd be like
come on let's promote gun because connor
[ __ ] off to hokkaido and ate some crap
didn't somebody like a famous uh i mean
politician got like it was like
newsworthy that he took maternity leave
a man
yeah like it was new it was newsworthy
that the man took a week off yeah yeah
he took
his paternity leave really yeah the man
took his entitled one week off
and it was it was literally country news
and he was allowed to but again
totally most people don't in japan
especially for maternity i think they
think that that's the mother's job right
yeah
that's the thing i feel japan in a lot
of sense is like the societal law
like almost exceeds the actual law you
know it's
it's like five steps forward in
technology and then their culture is
like hold up there's like 50 steps
hold up here's a fax machine yeah yeah
that's why i always say to people
coming to japan to work be careful where
you work um
foreign companies operating in japan
don't usually have those sort of
yeah unpleasant rules and parameters so
that's always a bonus but
be careful where you work because i know
a lot of people that work in jobs they
don't get any free time they're expected
to go out and drink a lot after work
there's no border between free time and
work it's hard drinking all the time
isn't it chris
12 i bet chris is like oh another
another night out really
oh i guess so because in in japan do you
have to like drink to show respect
no he's kind of it's right your boss
will like open up and talk
to you about things they wouldn't
normally do when they're sober in the
office right
even as a you know working in their
school my teachers that i worked with
but open up massively after
one drink they wouldn't even be drunk it
was almost like having alcohol would
initiate
being able to be open it's like being in
that environment yeah it opens them up
and i had teaching colleagues who'd just
be like i hate that colleague
i hate xyz i [ __ ] hate them and i'd
be like oh
okay he's like all right two beers maybe
we shouldn't have had a drink yeah
yeah the floodgate's open it's quite a
fascinating thing to experience
i love about two hours in we're finally
starting to sound like an actual podcast
i still keep laughing intermittently
because seeing connor die every time you
take a sip of sucking which is
[ __ ] hilarious to me let's do it
together
come on drink the whole thing i've got a
lot more oh
this is my second chris [ __ ] off look at
that this is my second are you trying to
get me drunk it's because you've been
having [ __ ] baby bird sips of that
[ __ ]
so [ __ ] all right cheers chris thank you
for this beautiful drink and beverage i
hope i don't throw up
to see dog v.a oh oh he's actually
downing it okay you know what
i love the fact that this is going to be
more edited than our hentai video
yeah right that's so disgusting
never shot suck it it's not designed for
that sec
come on it's in the same glass as well
it's contaminated with the [ __ ]
that you bought why chris made me down
this
disgusting abomination that is the
finest size this is
i bet this is the carlsberg of saggy
like
i bet this is if you don't know
carlsberg is a [ __ ] god-awful beer
um they're awful have you have you
noticed that in japan sometimes they'll
have carsberg or carling and they'll be
like foreign beer
and i'm like no no no no no i know
that's that's dirt water
yeah basically
you know and you're like no no no i know
what this is yeah
this is the good stuff [ __ ] off is this
the good stuff
but then again right like again like as
we were saying
connor's not a sake drinker in the same
way that he's not a whiskey drinker well
you've got wine now so
i used to be i used to watch white wine
from yamanashi you know when i first
came to japan i
desperately wanted to be that guy who
was like i love everything japan i'm i'm
a connoisseur of japan
i'm obsessed with sake press x to doubt
he was never [ __ ] like that
that was like i can't believe he just
looked at my face
when i wasn't with you when i go to a
bar and ask what drink do you want to be
like
sake of course oh yeah well every time
he wasn't with us
yeah of course because because i knew
that you would call me out on that [ __ ]
if i go to a bar and i'm like
but then when connor's there's just like
middle of light please yeah yeah but
when i'm actually like with you guys i'm
like beer please
but like because i don't want to be
called out like if if i'm with like
everyone right and everyone orders beer
and one person who's
on their first vacation to japan goes of
a sake actually
i'd be like [ __ ] off [ __ ] off you're
just getting too into the japan
atmosphere but it but it tastes like
[ __ ]
there's a reason there's a reason why a
bottle of sake never costs more than
twenty dollars
here's the thing i've noticed very
quickly about sake that i noticed about
just
regular wine is that i [ __ ] hate sake
normally
but if i have it with a good meal and
like a meal that
fits the sake i disagree then i [ __ ]
love it we've had no meal though
yeah that's why it took me a little
longer than usual
what's what got me to like wine was
having my first red wine with a nice
okay to be honest to be honest wine goes
fantastically with meals i agree it's
not
it's not a sake no it's no it's not
wine isn't too strong where like it's
overpowering sake is like when you when
you have your steak whatever and you
have a sake it's like
great now i've just [ __ ] who the [ __ ]
drinks sake with their steak what do you
eat it with
it's usually fish all right you have
fish right whatever the [ __ ] i don't
give a [ __ ] same thing
there's a reason why they serve a lot of
sake at like sushi restaurants
yeah but when you have it you have this
[ __ ] debate
and i just like you have the debate
chris help help me out here chris
chris because this is what happens when
we talk about food on the podcast okay
we always have the most heated debates
about food like whenever whenever foods
brought up we turned into a bunch of
[ __ ] apes i swear to god
like when people drink like hard liquor
with a meal or something i'm like
you have you are immediately just like
absolutely bombing your mouth is not a
hard liquor it's a wine
it's it's like 20 it's 20 so is wine
chris what are your opinion as the
adjudicator of this argument help me
get me out of here viewers dude red wine
is 15 to 20 percent
sake is 32 wine joey
you think i'm a [ __ ] wine sommelier
there is no wine that is 20
that is i've never seen that i've i have
seen that there's probably a wine that
is there
come on but no i like i much prefer wine
over sake um i feel like
12 to 15 is the perfect zone anything
above that starts to get like tastes
like vodka
right and sake
18 but that still tastes like a hard
alcohol
right no it doesn't burn did you lie it
doesn't bother you
wait did that burn for you yes eighteen
percent yeah eighty percent
like chris said that's not voc is thirty
seven point five yeah but the thing is
i can't distinguish the difference
between that and vodka that is why you
fail what are you on
no no what's wrong i'm not i was partly
on your side until you
you had the audacity to say that but
someone who
loves food so much taste the difference
between vodka and wine no
what i think is that that is strong
enough where it's in the same category
as a vodka taste
no no vodka makes me want to die more
100 but sake does still have the same
kind of quality of like i drink it i'm
like ah
immediately whereas the wine i'm like i
drink it and i'm like
oh i can't believe what i'm hearing oh
[ __ ] off
you're japanese okay you're a fan of
broccoli don't eat some [ __ ] whale
man
although all that chicken and broccoli
is [ __ ] your taste buds
seriously sucky on the same level as
vodka are you disgusting
listen they both taste like [ __ ] i mean
i'm not gonna [ __ ] down over i love
how this this
i love how we've gotten two hours into
this so we absolutely just drank a [ __ ]
ton of sake
unwillingly and now it's a mess of a
podcast thank you chris
i think if you watch this episode with a
bit of a bit of sucking some chicken
broccoli yeah
okay your least favorite alcohol is it
all on the same level because anything
above
20 percent is the [ __ ] same to you
then honestly
anything of like in like vodka tequila
whiskey
okay gin actually like i actually like
this this man contradicts himself i want
i want to be like phoenix wright right
now
being like there is a contradiction in
your statements
i jin jin actually tastes nice now i'm
not saying that no
no i'm not saying that because i'm
british and that that's that's our
cultural expert
are we talking like just gin on its own
or like a gin and tonic
tonic okay
name one person who drinks drinks gin
[ __ ] jin straight
no no one exactly because you don't hear
like when you have vodka and coke what
do you think i think depressing
university days like i'm desperate to
get drunk
yeah right chris yeah exactly ever
when's the last time when was the last
time you had a vodka and coke chris
i i vodka tonic like every week are you
okay chris
are you okay no i'm depressed i've
established this by now
okay a whiskey a whiskey you have
straight right you never like okay
whiskey and coke sounds like an
abomination right i wish he felt
great whiskey and coke's all right but i
mean like i i rarely drink whiskey
whiskey is more of a mood setter
whiskey is there for like yeah you don't
you don't want to get drunk on whiskey
no no
no i like i if people who get drunk on
whiskey
are drinking whiskey way too fast whis
is like kind of a drink that you just
kind of like
it warms you up but either way i don't
care for it right it's like a night cap
we all know the superior drink is an
espresso martini gentlemen right no
that's
that's because your body is just
addicted to caffeine i am i am this boy
drinks like
[ __ ] no no no christmas coffee eight
cups of coffee every day
get that wine down here go on let's try
the wine it's tainted with sake cup now
do you put it in the same disgusting cup
for the people you'd be a terrible
sommelier
no no well this one's right i'll be a
terrible
you want to be someone french can know i
would not be a terrible somalian i'm
going to get that out there right now
jordan how is it pronounced there we go
well that was closer to my pronunciation
yeah that's closer to my pronunciation
you didn't know
somalian somalia somalians watching this
a frog thing right now oh my god come on
it's like they noticed us
we have a resident french man who's
standing closer to my pronunciation than
yours
what what are you on i will fight this
battle to the death
i'm known for being stubborn and i won't
quit have you boys ever had soju
yeah yeah it's good okay why are you
asking me like you know i have no no no
because i of course i know you had soju
okay so like
i can't stand pure soju but for some
reason flavored soju
is just like so it's tea alcohol
so shoju is uh like korean kind of green
rice wine
yeah it's about korean sake how much is
it eight twenty percent is it it's way
more i can but the pure one is like
thirty
i don't drink the pure one i think the
flavored ones is it like twenty percent
and like
tastes like okay
soju is the only like kind of i agree
with that i can do that yeah
shots that goes well with beer i don't
know
why it actually does it actually does
dude it actually does say
this and then because you think of
mixing anything with beer
right and it sounds awful soju goes
[ __ ] amazing with beer especially
flavored soju pour a beer and then drop
the little
little shot in yeah
but awful night afterwards because again
that's like awful hangover
it will [ __ ] you up if our editor will
include this because he's the editor but
there's one
after the night where we bought like we
bought we bought
so for a party in the uk we did because
we were going to japan so we wanted to
do one last big party with all our
friends to celebrate
i know our editor came from a store
we're calling you out now
and uh we had i went to new malden
in london which is the korean uh area of
london
and i went to the korean like
supermarket and i i went and bought
like three crates of 20 of these bottles
yeah yeah
because there was about how many of us
was like 20. it was more than three
quarters there's four crates four crates
and they're all you know so we had 80
bottles of soju
and they're all like 750 milliliters
each time yeah
and um when i bought it as well they
were like you know how strong this is
right
yeah and i'm like yeah it's all good
was buying them he was like how many
crates should we buy and the
because he was posting this in the group
party chat and everyone's just like
hey more crates whatever right so we he
rocks up with four crates of soju
and we all look at this being like this
is this we've we've completely
overestimated
80 quid i've ever spent in my life we've
completely overestimated this
and so what happens is uh one of us
brought you know one of those like
beard and empty beer dispensers yeah we
can fill up with beer
yeah so we we just filled up this beer
dispenser with pure surgery
right so this entire party uh instead of
like having pints of beer we would
literally like just go to
go to this soju go to this go to the
soju dispenser
get a glass and just pour like ourselves
off
a full glass of soda it's awful
we drank like nearly all the crates in
the first place so
yeah on the first night we went through
three and a half crates of soju
between like about 25 of us so we had
bunk beds in this place so naturally
fine sick no no no no no actually no one
threw up i think actually
so so miracle so i'm sleeping in a bunk
bed with our editor and he's above not
inside tim bed
i wish that i'm kidding so i'm sitting
in the same bunk bed he's above me
and i wake up at like 6 a.m because
obviously sometimes you know you have to
drink you wake up a little bit yeah
yeah and i see him on the floor like
like this like
i'm i'm sitting on the bottom buck and
i'm like just like this
at like 6am and i'm like you okay he's
like
it hurts it hurts so much and i'm like
what's wrong he's like i'm so hungover
it hurts so much and i'm like
understandable i'm going back to bed
bye-bye i'm going back to bed oh my god
he was he was out of operation the whole
day was so funny
he's a great editor though thank you
estonians man oh that was a good party
so chris when are you going to come to
one of
a party in the uk with us we'll make
sure you whatever it is fantastic
i got really drunk and early hijacked a
boat with my estonian friend in london
wait wait wait wait you can't just say
that i can't go into detail
no wait come on chris [ __ ] time the
camera shuts off you just say this
offhand comment and you and we're just
like
whoa like can you like explain next next
episode of trash chase because you'll be
like this one time accidentally stole
the declaration of independence
totally funny story can't talk about it
though
come on come on set the scene drunk
nearly
the river thames had like a yacht uh
they had a party on a me and my estonian
friend crashed it
okay drunk and early like cast off how
did you nearly cast off well i was
really drunk and i found my way into the
engine room with the steering wheel
you don't just find your way into the
engine room you're actively trying it's
just some 24 [ __ ] he's on he's an
espionage mission
i am an esteemed youtuber i cannot talk
about food
i'm a nice person yeah i had a shot of
whiskey and found myself in a [ __ ]
mi6
that's kind of what it sounds it was one
kilometer from mi6 on the river
i could see my six from the boat
i love how mi6 you know this very
secretive thing is like that's the
building block it's like
giant in my sixth side of the building
it's like oh there it is
yeah i feel like i love how you made the
most interesting story into the most
throwaway tidbit
along the times where i used to rule
kazakhstan as well you know
classic stories from me chris
i accidentally became the king of
kazakhstan
there'll be a book one day that'll be a
very good book and i hope to promote him
chris chris ward king of cancer
[Music]
it was a facebook page of a screenshot
and it had chris's face on it
with
and it was like show me this on one look
you were like oh that's chris's facebook
page but then when you look closely
christopher broad christopher bull rad
of a bro a brown in japan
so but if he and apparently if you get
this message you've won five thousand
dollars
you've just been scared
kazakhstan i wish i wish i wish my
viewers were that creative
to come up with with those kind of
things
in japan you know what the worst the
most awkward thing i've ever had was
uh in that kind of sense is that at one
time but this is really back when i
started i almost had like maybe like 80k
subs so you know still quite small
and uh one time i got a skype uh friend
ad from someone back when skype was like
right still
not a boom that's how you know it's like
oh gee now yeah yeah and i added it and
i was like okay sure what this is back
when you would just be like [ __ ] yeah
i'll
just add anyone yeah and they were like
i why aren't you replying to my messages
when i added them and i'm like what
what who are you right what what are you
like why did you why don't you
i'm like why did you they're like and
then they're like why did you block me
in your other account
like what what what other account so
what happened was turns out right that
someone
had been pretending to be me on a
youtube channel right right and they had
and and so i got on call with them
because i was like [ __ ] it why not let's
get on
with this let's just see what's going on
right so so i call them up
and they're like they were like
absolutely panicking so i'm like all
right hold on
what's going on what's going on they're
like um i was dating you
and then we you stopped messaging me and
i'm like
you were dating me and i'm like this is
this is news to me
and they were like yeah i met you
through your youtube channel and then
they linked me my youtube channel
right right and it was someone who had
like pokemon like ruby
plastered all over their thing called
like sea dog va
right and they they were american doing
a terrible british accent right
pretending to be
pretending to be me right what so i was
like huh
and so you think this is me and they
were like yeah they said that
you this was your second channel and i'm
like yo
you have to be kidding me i thought they
were dating they thought they were
dating because this guy
because yeah because this guy apparently
was talking to her often and i'm like
do did he sound like me and she's like
yeah yeah he did so i looked on the
youtube videos
he sounded american as [ __ ] how'd he
sound like your voice
hey what's up guys it's cdawgva here
back with another pokemon ruby let's
play
and it was like totally i was like i was
dumbfounded at how
because at one part i felt sorry for
this woman because she was hysterical
but on the other i'm like
how do you fall i feel like you're gonna
lose your credit card at some point to
some
somalian like chris
you know and i was just i was like
dumbfounded i'm like all right and i
calmed her down i was like listen right
you meet up with her they
i did not that could have been the saga
the resolution yeah reach out to me
because they were clearly like you know
dumb
okay okay you know i don't like to call
my my viewers dumb
but but we can't say but listen chris
if you fall for that you're dumb this
yeah if a guy has a [ __ ] groud on us
their profile picture there should be
alarm bells in your head as to it not
being me
well maybe you're kind of like there is
some
you have to feel okay i feel sorry for
someone who would if they fell for
something
if they would pretend to be me but there
are certain levels of disbelief where
i'm like
this has got to be on you this is
you know it wasn't even a british accent
that's where i draw the line
wasn't even british do you even watch my
content the amount of videos there are
people
in like impersonating me for like funny
videos some of them are quite good yeah
but there's so many where it does not
even remotely sound like me and people
are falling in person and people
yeah yeah for videos like how so they'll
go on discord servers with the name sea
dog va yeah
they'll go in and they'll start talking
in like a facebook discord and then
uh sometimes my discord other discords
like like they go into voice chat and
stuff
right and um on a random service random
service
yeah it's for like funny videos some are
quite funny actually yeah yeah
and they'll they'll just do a really bad
british accent and everyone be like
oh my god it's sea dog va oh my god it's
him
and i'm sitting here at home like
seriously that's all it takes
oh apparently there's like a demographic
of your fans who watch your videos uh
muted
everyone everyone who is british sounds
like connor
i mean definitely a a lot of americans
can't tell the difference between a lot
of british accents
well i can get that i've yeah i've had a
lot of american folks like where are you
from in australia i'm like uh uh i'm not
afraid
i don't know why british australians
seem sick we do get mixed up quite a lot
even though
i think to us it's like it's like
completely opposite yeah yeah
you're i mean to me australian accents
are really different
he doesn't sound that australian i i
don't sound as yeah it doesn't sound
early in my channel i sound australian
as [ __ ] youtube really
same for me i sounded very northern yeah
i mean do you not sound less british as
you've gone you see this earlier
on the day i arrived in japan week one i
landed in yamagata
and my three teachers was going to work
with a meet me at the airport right and
i was like [ __ ] it up i had such a long
flower each time
i can't and they're like for one hour we
ate like a denny's
and they just couldn't understand
talking they kept going
afterwards they were like we don't we
didn't know what what you were saying
i never did the japanese canvas they're
like we didn't know what you were saying
right oh yeah and from then on i was
like hello my name is chris i'm from
london
area in the uk and i'd like to have to
change my voice
because i really like royal
pronunciation all right
i don't know that's how i used to speak
do you find sometimes that you speak
almost like broken english sometimes to
i've tried to stop doing that a lot of
english teachers in japan do the stupid
voice like
i went shopping with my friends
yesterday and they're like do you like
really
yeah i don't know yeah
sometimes i'll talk to people and i'll
just deconstruct my english live
just because i'm like i think they'll
understand if i say it this way
but then but then i'll go on to speak to
god and i'll be like hi
gant how are you today i'm you know
i don't know well i i lived in an
environment where for weeks at a time i
was the only foreigner around speaking
right
now my english level actually went down
is it weird not being able to speak
english for like a month
yeah it's really weird i've had bizarre
issues as a result but like yeah my
vocabulary never went down i couldn't
say words like
inconsequential that wouldn't come to my
mind that's what
that's what god just came to your mind i
was just like what what is going on
i would i just put me together i'd be
like i i i
just wouldn't come out i had that i had
that too that like when i first worked
in uh japanese school i worked in
nissico
it was like a big scheme resort in
hokkaido yes yeah
and i worked there for a month it was
like a kind of show snow
shovel general stuff around the lobbies
and stuff but all of the people who i
worked with were just 100
from hokkaido like all japanese people
so i was forced to basically speak
japanese for a month straight and i
remember i came back to australia
and i was like oh it's only been a month
right like of course this
english is my first language of course
i'm not going to forget it but then i
came back to australia i was like
[ __ ] what was that word again like i
actually i would actually forget
something consequential yeah i was like
something [ __ ] i don't i don't know how
to say it hard you know
yeah it was just really difficult but
like in in terms of like dumbing down
your language when speaking to like
you know japanese speakers i feel like
anyone who has come from like a
bilingual parents or like is bilingual
and has had like asian or
parents who don't speak your native
language as well
it's something i've just grown up with
because whenever i whenever i speak to
my parents
uh like mostly like for example when i
speak to my mom i mostly speak in thai
but when i have to express something in
english
i like very much have to dumb down very
careful about how i
word things because especially like
learning a language you know how their
grammar structure is
so you know like sometimes you hear a
japanese people like japanese person
speak try to speak english and you like
you understand
what their like mentality is or what
their like train of thought is when
they're trying to
like construct a sentence and you kind
of like what you kind of learn to do is
kind of mirror the way that
they would construct a sentence so that
they would eat more easily
yeah that's basically what i find myself
doing yeah but also oh dude i forget
like um so i'll think of a word in welsh
i'll be like and i'll remember the
japanese word
for it i'm like what the [ __ ] is it
which one is it and vice versa i'll be
speaking japanese
and i'll be like i own why is the welsh
word keep popping up in my head when i'm
trying to think of the right word
it's a mess because i obviously don't
use those languages as much i use
english so in my head they're slowly
like
amalgamating together and it's it's
awful i guess you're kind of getting to
the point and and you was all gone
you're kind of you guys came to the
point where you're
learning a third language right i mean
yeah i mean i
i'm trying japanese for you guys is
technically like a third language you're
trying to learn right
again i try and use it as much as
possible i mean i'm i'm doing like a
on the my new second channel
wow wow yeah plug i'm doing a series
where i'm uh i guess
playing games with japanese people and
using what broken japanese i have
yeah and sometimes i'm like about to say
a word i'm like nope that's that's the
welsh word
but if you haven't watched that you can
watch if you want to see my terrible my
terrible japanese in action but i do
find that that has been the best
practice i've had though
which is just talking oh yeah yeah
unfortunately i'm in a very
privileged situation where i don't need
to talk to japanese people
which i mean you know if you get a
japanese girlfriend every day is a
language lesson
what if they speak fluent english well
they screamed
and you're just gonna be speaking
english right right would you not find
that communication would be an issue if
you could um
i used to when i did the japanese girl
we used to have arguments i just didn't
know
what was going on right right in english
she didn't speak english very well i
didn't speak japanese at the time didn't
know what we were arguing about
because you just had your phones out of
the google translate yeah just because
when you when you think about it
when you think about it in english we
have so many ways to convey levels of
upset
that are so precise i feel that it's
almost
like impossible to translate that to a
non-native speaker
i mean it's you know it's the whole idea
of like right the word [ __ ]
right like that could be used in
literally any emotion
but trying to i had to i had to explain
that to one of my japanese friends
because he had heard of that word before
but he was like what does it actually
mean
i was like what have you wanted well
it's kind of use your imagination yeah
when i say that when i said it
it could mean anything he was just like
what what does that mean my experience
teaching my japanese friends word [ __ ]
it's dangerous because they'll just use
it they use it every time yeah big [ __ ]
i mean he's like the soul absolutely
yeah big [ __ ]
he went to like a love hotel when he
referred to it as a scary [ __ ] point
um he would be completely correct
what he was trying to say was this is a
[ __ ] scary place
for some for some reason when i've been
meeting japanese people online on video
games they seem to only know
the worst words like for one this one
guy kept telling me he had a magnum
oh chinchin
and i was like how do you know the word
magnum
that is such how would you know who
taught you this
who how do you find this out i love how
he loves he knows the word magnum but
not the word for penis
it was just so yeah the dichotomy of
magnum ocean
[Music]
it was great they'd asked me about my
dick size live on stream and i'm like
are you sure you want to ask that
it's so good i learned that there's also
a they have a
term and gaming in japan where they have
real tamil
yeah so when you game online with people
they're not the real friends
right and when sometimes if you're busy
you're like oh i'm playing with real
tamil
is like the equivalent of like irl
friends yeah which is like funny because
it's like you're not real
real you're my gaming friend you're not
my real yeah
i've i've been learning a lot they're
doing that yeah there's a there's a lot
of like
japanese i guess like internet slang
you'll learn from playing with
japanese yeah luckily i've been playing
with one guy and he's been he's been
figuring out how to like dumb things
down for me right which is good because
sometimes he talks too he was like
throwing out like two-chan lingo because
they feel like they thought they never
used like
like any uh they always use like plain
form and stuff like that and throw a
like
[ __ ] this is not like my classes
what's all this nonsense
where is
what's going on here
i feel like watashi was the biggest
[ __ ] lie you learned yeah
yeah yeah nobody says that yeah on
duolingo
it constantly throws watashi non-stop at
you it's the first thing you learn
right every japanese textbook in every
classroom and then you talk to them and
you're like so that was a [ __ ] lie
no no i meant just say now to everyone
who messaged me every day saying they've
learned japanese from duolingo
it doesn't prepare you for japanese do
you really think not at all it's quite
fun but like
it won't prepare you on the ground no
mini game it is it's
nice it helps with vocab but that's
honestly as far as it goes but even then
i
because sometimes duolinguo try and
teach you kanji
before it's even taught you all the
hiragana and catacombs which blows my
mind
yeah yeah yeah it's insane it did do
that i think we've talked about that
that's like teaching you like algebra
before you've learned multiplication
right
yeah duolingo is all right but like
human japanese really good app i
recommend
um it is paid for but it's like a free
lite version but i i don't mind paying
for an app if it actually is good it is
really i used it in my first year human
japanese human japanese intermediate
everyone i've recommended to loves it so
if you're learning japanese you're like
really
starting tomorrow afternoon human
japanese amazing do you recommend the
genki textbooks
they're good after like you've done
japanese studying because that's like
that's like the one
japanese you've started studying
tomorrow you come in japan that is the
app you get
that really
well that's been this episode of press
taste it's been the messiest episode of
trash time
i like how this like this is going to be
even more edited than the hentai video
and i'm just like
how how thank you to our patreons that's
it patrons here there's all these lovely
people who are helping you
this is the second time we've said it
because joey said it like a [ __ ] hour
ago and then we
did like we were just getting the flow
of chat and [ __ ]
yes sir i don't know i'm i'm not in the
right place i hope you've enjoyed this
recorded
bar episode
chris if this is a mess it's chris's
fault
because of the trash taste pub because
chris brought his equivalent of boxed
wine sake
[ __ ] abomination that was good why do
you talk about twelve dollars like
that's like you're in uni still like
that's like this is the top shelf
there's good stuff that
if you'd like to support the show though
then make sure to go to patreon.com
also go follow us on twitter and our
subreddit and also if you're an audio
listener go check us out on spotify
also go check out the first episode that
uh chris is in yeah yeah
that was like how many episodes ago a
long time ago a long time ago
back when the set was still blend right
it was completely empty wasn't it yes
yeah did we have figures good now
no no we had no it was right after it
was right it was like the one after that
right still very barren though but yeah
we ever see chris on for the third time
who knows
please probably please have me back
i used to write every day please have me
back on mr connor and joey
it's getting really annoying hearing the
banging outside all the time
but uh no i've had a lot of fun today
all right well done guys for turning
trash taste into a
success like the first time i came very
early on now it's an empire no less
i prefer a monopoly thank you very much
and you're
you know at the time we live in a
society you're close to a million
subscribers
that's pretty awesome in a very short
space of time right i mean
you're gonna hit that very soon in 2021
i hope so
well done to make it a great happy new
year happy new year to 2021 tons of
trash taste to come
you guys got as drunk as we did on new
year's eve
should definitely watch this with a
drink of wine or sake or like i really
shouldn't have had a power salad before
i came on because i didn't
i would like to say before these boys
start rambling more you can expect
all the good [ __ ] from trash taste this
year we've only been around for like
half a year now but
we've done we've done some good stuff so
far and you can expect even better stuff
coming this year absolutely
absolutely it's a trash taste promise
whatever more guests
taste probably whatever that means just
wait until the country opens up
all right we can reach our final form
all right thank you very much for
watching i've been
your boy and i've been with the boy the
not
it's your boy it's your boy chris
goodbye good day to you sir all right
cheers have a good one guys i'll cheers
to that
cheers boys thanks guys thanks for
watching to continue continuing this
off-camera god damn it
god i hate christmas [ __ ] sake
[Music]
you